This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When David Pizarro was five years old, he was at a weekly church meeting with his family. The grown-ups went to visit with each other while the children, including David, were left to their own devices. And my sister and her little friend thought that they would play a fun game with me, and that game involved making me lie down, close my eyes, and open my mouth. They wouldn't tell David what was going to happen. It was to be a surprise. I sort of naively trusting of my dear older sister,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。大卫·皮萨罗五岁时，正和家人参加每周一次的教会聚会。大人们聚在一起聊天，而孩子们，包括大卫在内，则被留在一旁自己玩耍。我姐姐和她的小伙伴想跟我玩个有趣的游戏，游戏的内容是让我躺下，闭上眼睛，张开嘴。她们没告诉大卫接下来会发生什么。这本该是个惊喜。我当时天真地信任着我亲爱的姐姐，
who by the way is an attorney now, sure enough, closed my eyes and opened my mouth, and I felt something soft, wet, and sort of cold in my mouth. And I immediately spit, opened my eyes, and I saw my sister and her little friend laugh. If you're eating something right now, I'd advise you to put it down. What they had put in my mouth was, I don't recall exactly what food it was, but it was partially chewed food that the other little girl had decided to chew up,
顺便说一下，她现在是一名律师。我果然闭上眼睛张开了嘴，然后我感觉到嘴里有什么柔软、湿润且有点凉的东西。我立刻吐了出来，睁开眼睛，看到姐姐和她的小伙伴在笑。如果你现在正在吃东西，我建议你把它放下。她们放进我嘴里的东西，我不记得具体是什么食物了，但那是另一个小女孩决定嚼碎的半咀嚼食物，
put in her hand, and then stick right in my mouth. David's sister and her friend thought the whole thing was hilarious. I've never felt so betrayed. This is one of the key moments in my life where I was so disgusted. I don't remember throwing up, but I can tell you for sure that I felt like throwing up. And I, to this day, can remember the texture, the temperature, the feeling of that food in my mouth. Wow. As you're telling the story, I have to confess, I can feel my stomach turning here, David.
放在手里，然后直接塞进我嘴里。大卫的姐姐和她的朋友觉得整件事非常搞笑。我从未感到如此被背叛。这是我一生中感到极度恶心的关键时刻之一。我不记得自己有没有呕吐，但我可以肯定地告诉你，我当时感觉想吐。直到今天，我还能记得那种食物在我嘴里的质地、温度和感觉。哇。当你讲述这个故事时，我必须承认，大卫，我能感觉到我的胃在翻腾。
I apologize. My sister's a lovely, wonderful person now. I have not forgiven her, but I won't hold it against her. Disgust is a profound emotion. It doesn't just shape childhood pranks. It also shapes our relationships, our values, who we choose as friends, and who we think of as foes. In fact, disgust turns out to be so powerful, so primal,
我很抱歉。我姐姐现在是一个可爱、很棒的人。我没有原谅她，但我不会记恨她。恶心是一种深刻的情绪。它不仅塑造了童年的恶作剧。它还塑造了我们的人际关系、我们的价值观、我们选择谁作为朋友，以及我们认为谁是敌人。事实上，恶心被证明是非常强大、非常原始的，
that pollsters and politicians are using it to manipulate. us today. The Psychology of Disgust this week on Hidden Brain. Disgust is an emotion we all feel. It's that strong reaction we get when we sense something unpleasant, a foul odor, spoiled food, toxic waste.
以至于民意调查员和政客们今天正在利用它来操纵我们。《恶心的心理学》，本周在《隐藏的大脑》播出。恶心是我们所有人都会感受到的情绪。当我们感知到令人不快的事物，比如难闻的气味、变质的食物、有毒废物时，我们就会产生这种强烈的反应。
Disgust doesn't just shape our perceptions. It transforms our behavior. Take a bite of a rotten cucumber, and we might never eat a cucumber again. See a deadfly in our soup, and we might never return to our restaurant again and might even swear off soup. At Cornell University,
恶心不仅塑造了我们的感知。它还改变了我们的行为。咬一口腐烂的黄瓜，我们可能再也不会吃黄瓜了。在汤里看到一只死苍蝇，我们可能再也不会回到那家餐馆，甚至可能发誓不再喝汤。在康奈尔大学，
psychologist David Pizarro studies disgust. He's interested in how it shapes the way we see the world. David Pizarro, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. David, in 1960, the U.S. presidential race featured a sitting vice president, Richard Nixon, and a senator named John F. Kennedy. Now, JFK's youth and inexperience was seen
心理学家大卫·皮萨罗研究恶心。他感兴趣的是这种情绪如何塑造我们看待世界的方式。大卫·皮萨罗，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。大卫，1960年，美国总统竞选的双方是时任副总统理查德·尼克松和参议员约翰·F·肯尼迪。当时，JFK的年轻和缺乏经验被视为
as major vulnerabilities, and it was the first presidential race where the candidates faced off in a debate on television. The candidates need no introduction. The Republican candidate, Vice President Richard M. Nixon, and the Democratic candidate, Senator John F. candidate. Can you paint me a picture of what happened when viewers tuned into that debate? Yeah, well, you know, Nixon had an advantage the polls were showing.
主要的弱点，而且这是总统候选人首次在电视辩论中交锋。候选人无需介绍。共和党候选人，副总统理查德·M·尼克松，以及民主党候选人，参议员约翰·F·肯尼迪。你能为我描绘一下观众收看那场辩论时发生了什么吗？是的，你知道，民调显示尼克松当时有优势。
As you said, John F. Kennedy was young and fairly inexhaired. experienced. And in preparation for these debates, Kennedy actually did some decent preparing. The question before the American people is, are we doing as much as we can do? Are we as strong as we should be? Are we as strong as we must be if we're going to maintain our independence? He had met with people about how he would look, about his appearance. Nixon, on the other hand, maybe because he had recently been hospitalized, maybe just because he didn't take it seriously or didn't know, got into the debates looking pale, sickly, sweaty. I do believe that he would agree that I am just as sincere in believing that my proposals
正如你所说，约翰·F·肯尼迪很年轻，而且相当缺乏经验。在准备这些辩论时，肯尼迪确实做了一些不错的准备。摆在美国人民面前的问题是，我们是否在尽我们所能？我们是否像我们应该的那样强大？如果我们想保持独立，我们是否像我们必须的那样强大？他曾与人商讨过自己的形象，关于他的外表。另一方面，尼克松，也许是因为他最近刚出院，也许只是因为他没有认真对待或者不知道，参加辩论时看起来脸色苍白、病恹恹的、满头大汗。我相信他会同意，我在相信我的联邦教育援助提案、我的帮助提案方面是同样真诚的。
for federal aid education, my proposals for help. And once the debate got underway, I understand, you know, Nixon had not used any makeup when he went before the television cameras, and it can get pretty hot under those lights. Yeah, and those lights used to be extremely hot. And so what the U.S. was able to see on these live televised debates was a person who looked a little bit diseased, perhaps, not at his best. In fact, Nixon's sweaty, pale appearance with no makeup, of course, now we understand that to be under, to on a camera at all we always put on makeup. Nixon looked so bad that even his mother was concerned
一旦辩论开始，据我了解，你知道，尼克松在电视摄像机前没有使用任何化妆品，而在那些灯光下会变得非常热。是的，那些灯光过去非常热。所以美国在这些电视直播辩论中看到的是一个看起来有点病态的人，也许，不是他最好的状态。事实上，尼克松满头大汗、脸色苍白且没有化妆，当然，现在我们明白，只要在摄像机前，我们总是会化妆。尼克松看起来太糟糕了，以至于连他的母亲都很担心，
and reached out to him afterwards, wondering if he was okay. Now, it's hard to know what the effect of one debate was on the outcome of the race, but many presidential scholars think the debate did undermine Nixon. So JFK came off as fresh and youthful, and Nixon came across as, you know, unshaven and sweaty. Yeah, most people just generally agree that this. was a turning point in that election. Like you say, we can never know about the substance,
事后还联系他，想知道他是否还好。现在，很难知道一场辩论对竞选结果有什么影响，但许多总统学者认为这场辩论确实削弱了尼克松。所以JFK显得清新年轻，而尼克松给人的印象是，你知道，没刮胡子且满头大汗。是的，大多数人普遍认为这是那次选举的转折点。就像你说的，我们永远无法了解实质内容，
but we know now from decades of research that appearance matters, that the way in which these candidates presented themselves had perhaps an undue effect on public opinion at the time, but of course at the time we didn't realize what a strong influence the appearance of the candidates would have. Let's move forward to more recent history during the U.S. presidential debate on September 10th, 2024,
但我们现在从几十年的研究中知道，外表很重要，候选人展示自己的方式可能对当时的公众舆论产生了不当的影响，但当然在当时，我们并没有意识到候选人的外表会有如此强大的影响力。让我们转向更近的历史，在2024年9月10日的美国总统辩论中，
Republican candidate Donald Trump made a claim about immigrants in Springfield, Ohio. In Springfield, they're eating the dogs, the people that came in, they're eating the cats, they're eating the pets of the people that live there. Where did this claim come from, David? Well, it seems as if this was a rumor start. by a local Facebook group out there in Springfield, Ohio, claiming that a local cat had been butchered. And, you know, some far-right neo-Nazi groups took that claim and ran
共和党候选人唐纳德·特朗普对俄亥俄州斯普林菲尔德的移民提出了一个主张。在斯普林菲尔德，他们在吃狗，那些进来的人，他们在吃猫，他们在吃住在那里的居民的宠物。这个主张是从哪里来的，大卫？嗯，看起来这似乎是一个谣言，由俄亥俄州斯普林菲尔德当地的一个Facebook群组发起，声称当地的一只猫被屠宰了。而且，你知道，一些极右翼的新纳粹团体采纳了这个说法并大肆宣扬，
and started claiming that these were Haitian immigrants that were stealing and eating local pets. Now, the claim was quickly debunked, but I understand it had some pretty profound consequences when, you know, people started to imagine these scenes of these immigrants, basically essentially eviscerating and eating, you know, the local pets. Yeah, you know, it took on a life of its own. And as we now know, debunking isn't always so effective because once people began spreading this, it almost didn't matter what the truth was.
开始声称是海地移民在偷吃当地宠物。现在，这个说法很快就被揭穿了，但我明白它产生了一些相当深远的影响，当人们开始想象这些移民基本上是在剖开并吃掉当地宠物时。是的，你知道，它有了自己的生命。而且正如我们现在所知，揭穿谣言并不总是那么有效，因为一旦人们开始传播它，真相几乎就不重要了。
People in Springfield started getting bomb threats. There were evacuations of public buildings, including the city hall. Local Haitian immigrants were reporting that they were being harassed and that they feared for their safety. I remember when I heard the story, you know, I wasn't sure about the veracity of the story, but it was such an emotionally powerful story. I remember feeling, recoiling in some ways,
斯普林菲尔德的人们开始收到炸弹威胁。公共建筑，包括市政厅，进行了疏散。当地海地移民报告说他们受到骚扰，并担心自己的人身安全。我记得当我听到这个故事时，你知道，我不确定故事的真实性，但它是一个情感上非常有力的故事。我记得我感到，在某种程度上退缩了，
of the idea of people, you know, cutting open cats and dogs and eating them. Yeah, I think that's probably a pretty common response that we all had. I mean, if there was a story that would get at the heart of, especially Americans, it would be something to do with being mean to our dogs. But in that particularly grisly way. So speaking of Donald Trump, in 2019, a 20-foot balloon was paraded down the streets of London. It depicted the once-and-future U.S. president.
想到人们剖开猫狗并吃掉它们。是的，我认为这可能是我们所有人都会有的相当普遍的反应。我的意思是，如果有一个故事能触动，特别是美国人的心，那一定是关于虐待我们的狗的事情。但以那种特别可怕的方式。说到唐纳德·特朗普，2019年，一个20英尺高的气球在伦敦街头游行。它描绘了这位曾经和未来的美国总统。
What was remarkable about this balloon, David? Well, when they designed the balloon, they decided to make President Trump a giant baby. There was even a hashtag diaper dawn that sort of was viral because of the power of this image. So all the examples we've discussed, a sweaty presidential candidate, a claim about immigrants eating dogs and cats, the depiction of Donald Trump as a baby in a diaper. All of these events seem to be cut from the same cloth, David. What are these stories induce in us?
这个气球有什么特别之处，大卫？嗯，当他们设计这个气球时，他们决定把特朗普总统做成一个巨大的婴儿。甚至还有一个标签“尿布唐”，因为这个形象的力量而走红。所以我们讨论的所有例子，一个满头大汗的总统候选人，关于移民吃猫狗的主张，将唐纳德·特朗普描绘成一个穿着尿布的婴儿。所有这些事件似乎都是一脉相承的，大卫。这些故事在我们心中引发了什么？
Well, at least one of the things that they all induce, in me and many other people is the emotion of disgust. There is something that makes us recoil, a word that I believe he used, Shankar, makes us have a visceral sense of a version against
嗯，它们至少引发的一件事，在我以及许多其他人心中，就是恶心的情绪。有一些东西让我们退缩，尚卡尔，我相信你用了这个词，让我们对这些图像、这些想法产生了一种发自内心的厌恶感。
these images, these thoughts. Now, I've always associated disgust with, you know, yucky smells or food that I dislike. But what these examples are showing is that disgust is not just in the realm of what we eat or what we smell, it's also in the realm of
现在，我一直把恶心与，你知道，恶心的气味或我不喜欢的食物联系在一起。但这些例子表明，恶心不仅存在于我们吃什么或闻什么的领域，它也存在于公共生活和政治领域。
public life and in politics. Yeah, that's one of the interesting things about this emotion. Many scholars, in fact, I think most scholars who study the emotion have discussed would agree that if it has a function, you know, if it has a purpose, that purpose is to prevent us from getting sick from contamination by touching something that might make us sick. But that emotion does seem to have expanded and it actually is easy to elicit and is often elicited in our everyday life. From shaping elections to influencing our ideologies,
是的，这是这种情绪有趣的地方之一。事实上，许多学者，我认为大多数研究这种情绪的学者都会同意，如果它有一种功能，你知道，如果它有一个目的，那个目的就是防止我们因接触可能让我们生病的东西而受到污染。但这种情绪似乎已经扩展了，而且实际上很容易被激发，并且经常在我们的日常生活中被激发。从塑造选举到影响我们的意识形态，
disgust turns out to play a big role in politics in public life. When we come back, how an emotion that evolved to keep us safe from germs and pathogens is increasingly being weaponized in public life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantanth. Picture this. You walk into a bathroom at a gas station. The fluorescent lights flicker on and cockroaches scatter.
恶心在政治和公共生活中扮演着重要角色。回来后，我们将探讨一种为了保护我们免受细菌和病原体侵害而进化的情绪，是如何在公共生活中日益被武器化的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。想象一下。你走进一个加油站的厕所。荧光灯闪烁着亮起，蟑螂四散奔逃。
You step into the stall. The floor is slick with an unidentifiable slimy sludge, and the toilet looks like it hasn't been flushed in a while. Now take a moment to notice your reaction. Is your lip curling? There's a good chance your whole face has contorted into a grimace. Disgust will do that to you. At Cornell University, psychologist David Pizarro is interested in the psychology of disgust and how it shapes our lives in unseen ways.
你走进隔间。地板上满是无法辨认的黏糊糊的污泥，马桶看起来很久没冲了。现在花点时间注意你的反应。你的嘴唇在撇吗？你的整张脸很有可能已经扭曲成了一个鬼脸。恶心会让你那样。在康奈尔大学，心理学家大卫·皮萨罗对恶心的心理学感兴趣，以及它如何以看不见的方式塑造我们的生活。
So, David, is disgust emotional or something biological? Well, it's a good question. It's a little of both, right? I mean, most of our emotions, as we understand them, are produced by our biology. But your question is getting to something that I think is extra interesting about disgust. because disgust, perhaps unlike some of our other emotions, seems so tied to our biology. On the one hand, it's tied to our biology because it's so related to the things that we touch and that we eat that might make us sick. So in that sense, it feels like a biological emotion, a biological response.
那么，大卫，恶心是情绪化的还是生物学上的东西？嗯，这是一个好问题。两者都有，对吧？我的意思是，我们的大部分情绪，据我们所知，都是由我们的生物学产生的。但你的问题触及了我认为关于恶心特别有趣的一点。因为恶心，也许不像我们其他的一些情绪，似乎与我们的生物学联系得如此紧密。一方面，它与我们的生物学联系在一起，因为它与我们触摸和食用的可能让我们生病的东西如此相关。所以从这个意义上说，它感觉像是一种生物学情绪，一种生物学反应。
But it's also very reflexive. It doesn't require a whole lot of thought. So some of our emotions require us to have opinions or to make judgments about the world. Disgust doesn't seem to take that much. So that feeling that I had of the texture of the food that got put in my mouth, that was such an immediate reflexive, negative reaction that some people actually prefer to call disgust something like a reflex rather than emotion. So discuss shapes our lives from the time we are very young to when we are very old. When you were in the fifth grade, you and many of your classmates picked on a kid.
但它也非常反射性。它不需要太多的思考。所以我们的一些情绪需要我们有观点或对世界做出判断。恶心似乎不需要那么多。所以那种食物质地进入我嘴里的感觉，那是一种如此直接的反射性、负面反应，以至于有些人实际上更喜欢称恶心为一种反射，而不是情绪。所以恶心塑造了我们的生活，从我们很小的时候到我们很老的时候。当你上五年级时，你和你的许多同学欺负了一个孩子。
What did this kid do to set you off? You know, this is a sad story for me because the kid did nothing. The kid, you know, this young boy was a normal, fun, intelligent young boy, but there was something that he had that really brought out the worst in us. And that was he would come to school smelling bad. I don't know what the smell was. I don't know why he had it. It smelled like he was unwashed. It smelled maybe a little bit like he had a dirty diaper even.
这个孩子做了什么让你反感？你知道，这对我来说是一个悲伤的故事，因为那个孩子什么也没做。那个孩子，你知道，这个小男孩是一个正常、有趣、聪明的年轻男孩，但他身上有一些东西确实激发出我们最坏的一面。那就是他来学校时闻起来很难闻。我不知道那是什么气味。我不知道他为什么会有这种气味。闻起来好像他没洗澡。闻起来甚至有点像他带着脏尿布。
And because of that, we shunned him. We spoke about it behind his back. And unfortunately, I think that his social life suffered because of our inability to look past that disgust. So disgust might have evolved to protect us from danger to keep us from eating rotten food, but it also prompts us toward cruelty. Yeah, that's right. So it's like many things that have evolved via natural selection. It's an imperfect mechanism.
正因为如此，我们避开了他。我们在背后议论他。不幸的是，我认为他的社交生活因为我们无法超越那种恶心而受到了影响。所以恶心可能进化是为了保护我们免受危险，防止我们吃腐烂的食物，但它也促使我们变得残忍。是的，没错。所以它就像通过自然选择进化的许多事物一样。它是一个不完美的机制。
It's a very efficient mechanism to keep us from, like you said, ingesting things that might be dangerous for us. So a lot of people talk about sort of parasite avoidance or disease avoidance. It works well like that. But of course, it's not perfect because the way that it works is that it responds, it is elicited by certain cues that just tend to be correlated with things that might be bad for you. So particular smells that might be associated with something that's dangerous to touch or eat are going to make us feel disgusted. But of course, not everything that makes us sick is disgusting to us. and many things that are discussing to us pose no danger whatsoever. So disgust can also make us do irrational things.
它是一个非常有效的机制，可以防止我们，就像你说的，摄入可能对我们危险的东西。所以很多人谈论寄生虫规避或疾病规避。它那样工作得很好。但当然，它并不完美，因为它的工作方式是它响应，它被某些往往与可能对你有害的事物相关的线索所激发。所以某些可能与触摸或食用危险事物相关的气味会让我们感到恶心。但当然，并非所有让我们生病的东西都让我们感到恶心。而且许多让我们感到恶心的东西根本不构成任何危险。所以恶心也会让我们做一些非理性的事情。
You and others have looked at the role of disgust in medicine, like screenings for certain kinds of cancer. Yeah, in fact, a lot of people may avoid engaging in behaviors that are good for them because they have concerns surrounding disgust. So, for instance, people might not get colorectal screening because they're grossed out at the thought of, doing this procedure, or they might actually be concerned that the medical practitioners themselves will be grossed out at them, at their own bodies. And so disgust can play this powerful,
你和其他人研究了恶心在医学中的作用，比如某些癌症的筛查。是的，事实上，很多人可能会避免从事对他们有益的行为，因为他们对恶心有顾虑。所以，例如，人们可能不会进行结直肠癌筛查，因为他们对进行这种手术的想法感到恶心，或者他们实际上可能担心医疗从业者自己会对他们，对他们自己的身体感到恶心。所以恶心可以扮演这种强大的、
motivating role in unfortunately leading us to do things that aren't good for us. We've had the great psychologist Paul Rosen on Hidden Brain before, and he's done a lot of work in this area looking at how disgust influences our thoughts and preferences. One of the things he has explored is the idea of contagion when it comes to disgust. Can you explain what this is, David? The idea with disgust that separates it, in my opinion, from many of our other emotions, is that it spreads through contagion, through contamination, as Paul Rosen pointed out. So if I touch something that is disgusting, I am now disgusting to many people.
激励性的角色，不幸的是导致我们做一些对我们不利的事情。我们之前在《隐藏的大脑》中请过伟大的心理学家保罗·罗森，他在这个领域做了大量工作，研究恶心如何影响我们的思想和偏好。他探索的事情之一是恶心方面的传染概念。你能解释一下这是什么吗，大卫？关于恶心的想法，在我看来，它与我们许多其他情绪的区别在于，它通过传染，通过污染传播，正如保罗·罗森指出的那样。所以如果我触摸了令人恶心的东西，我现在对许多人来说就是令人恶心的。
And other emotions don't seem to work this way, right? So if I'm afraid of a lion and Shankar, you go and you get close to that lion, I am not now afraid of you, right? There is nothing in the contact between you and the lion that has transferred. But disgust seems to work on this principle of association of contact. Things can get contaminated with each other. And that's how disgust sort of transmits out spreads. Why is it that this contagion only works in one direction? So, you know, a single cockroach on a platter of food can make the whole thing inedible, but pouring, you know, a gallon of honey on a cockroach doesn't make it less disgusting. That's very, yeah, this is what Paul Rawson does refer to as this negativity dominance, and it's a very interesting feature. My best guess at what's going on here is that consistent with what disgust has evolved to do, it discussed has evolved to as we've said now many times keep us from contamination
而其他情绪似乎不是这样工作的，对吧？所以如果我害怕狮子，而尚卡尔，你走过去靠近那只狮子，我现在并没有害怕你，对吧？你和狮子之间的接触中没有任何东西转移了。但恶心似乎遵循这种关联、接触的原则。事物可以相互污染。这就是恶心传播的方式。为什么这种传染只在一个方向上起作用？所以，你知道，一盘食物里的一只蟑螂可以让整盘食物无法食用，但把一加仑蜂蜜倒在蟑螂上并不会让它变得不那么恶心。这非常，是的，这就是保罗·罗森所说的这种负面主导地位，这是一个非常有趣的特征。我对他这里发生的事情的最佳猜测是，与恶心进化所要做的保持一致，正如我们现在已经多次说过的，恶心进化是为了让我们远离污染，
keep us from getting diseases and the way that that germs work is that coming into contact with something that has germs can pass germs in that way so one small thing that might make my cup of soup contaminated that might make me sick cannot be reversed and the other way, you can't put a little bit of soup in all the viruses and make things okay. Now, Paul Rosen and others have found that people still feel disgust even when there is no threat at all. So it's one thing to say, you know, a fly in your soup makes the whole bowl of soup inedible. But even when there is no threat at all, Paul Rosen and others find that disgust still works its contamination magic. Tell me about the sympathetic magical law of contagion.
让我们远离疾病，而细菌的工作方式是接触带有细菌的东西可以通过这种方式传播细菌，所以一件可能让我的汤杯受到污染、可能让我生病的小东西是无法逆转的，反之亦然，你不能在所有的病毒中加入一点汤让事情变得好起来。现在，保罗·罗森和其他人发现，即使根本没有威胁，人们仍然会感到恶心。所以说苍蝇在汤里让整碗汤无法食用是一回事。但即使根本没有威胁，保罗·罗森和其他人发现恶心仍然发挥着它的污染魔力。告诉我关于同情魔法传染律的事情。
Yeah, well, Rawson, he brought together this idea that in traditional cultures, magic works through this sympathetic transmission. And disgust seems to be magical like that as well. That is, magical in the sense that even when we know physically that there is no danger, we can't shake the fact that we're disgusted by something. So to give you an example, and this comes from studies that Rosin and many others have done, even if I can let you know that I am sterilizing a cockroach, right, that there is absolutely no danger. And I put it in your drink. I just dip it into your drink and I remove it.
是的，嗯，罗森，他提出了一个观点，即在传统文化中，魔法通过这种同情传播起作用。而恶心似乎也像那样具有魔力。也就是说，魔力在于，即使我们从物理上知道没有危险，我们也无法摆脱我们对某事感到恶心的事实。所以给你举个例子，这来自罗森和许多其他人所做的研究，即使我可以让你知道我正在对一只蟑螂进行消毒，对吧，绝对没有危险。然后我把它放进你的饮料里。我只是把它浸入你的饮料里，然后把它拿出来。
That's not going to make you feel that much better about the cockroach. Now, you might think, well, do I trust Pizarro? Do I trust Rosen to have sterilized? this. But even in more extreme cases, so if I have a piece of string that you know is clean, and that's touching your drink, and the other end of that string, maybe five feet down the line, it's touching some dog feces. People still, many people are reluctant to take a sit from their drink, knowing full well that the germs from the dog feces haven't even had time to travel to their drink. So that's why,
那并不会让你对那只蟑螂感觉好多少。现在，你可能会想，嗯，我信任皮萨罗吗？我信任罗森消毒过这个吗？但即使在更极端的情况下，所以如果我有一根你知道是干净的绳子，它正在接触你的饮料，而那根绳子的另一端，也许在五英尺外，正在接触一些狗粪。人们仍然，许多人不愿意从他们的饮料中喝一口，完全知道狗粪中的细菌甚至还没有时间传播到他们的饮料中。这就是为什么，
I think Rosen refers to this as magical, why he's bringing the term sympathetic magic into this. I remember visiting the Exploratorium in San Francisco many years ago, and they had a wonderful little exhibit where they had a drinking fountain, but the drinking fountain was embedded inside a toilet. And it was clearly marked as a drinking fountain. It had never been used as a toilet, but still the idea of leaning over the toilet and drinking from this drinking fountain. and was simply, you know, it was not possible to do. Are you supposed to drink this? It feels kind of weird because you're drinking out of a toilet. Yeah, I feel that very strongly.
我认为罗森称之为魔力，为什么他把同情魔法这个词引入其中。我记得多年前参观旧金山的探索博物馆，他们有一个很棒的小展览，里面有一个饮水机，但饮水机嵌入在一个马桶里。它被清楚地标记为饮水机。它从未被用作马桶，但仍然，弯腰对着马桶从这个饮水机喝水的想法，根本无法做到。你是要喝这个吗？感觉有点奇怪，因为你是在马桶里喝水。是的，我对此感觉非常强烈。
I am somebody, the audience might have guessed. I am somebody who is easily disgusted. And yes, even if I knew rationally, I still would probably refuse to do it. But this is one of the ways that emotions work and why they work so powerfully. If it were the case that some of our emotional responses could so easily be overridden by our beliefs, then they might not have the same effect, right? Part of the reason that they work so well is that they can bypass our rational faculties. I don't have to think, for instance, whether a bear poses a real threat.
我是一个，听众可能已经猜到了。我是一个很容易感到恶心的人。是的，即使我理性地知道，我可能还是会拒绝这样做。但这正是情绪工作的方式之一，也是它们为何如此有力地工作的原因。如果我们的某些情绪反应能如此容易地被我们的信念所覆盖，那么它们可能就不会有同样的效果，对吧？它们工作得如此好的部分原因是它们可以绕过我们的理性能力。例如，我不必思考熊是否构成真正的威胁。
If it's running toward me, I'm running away. Yeah. So there seems to be a connection between the mind and the body when it comes to disgust. And you say the logic of disgust can spill into our social and moral thinking, too. So if a morally impure person comes into contact with something sacred, the thing that is pure is now seen as tarnished or defiled. There are a couple of ways in which disgust seems to infuse itself into our social life. And one way is that if we describe or feel or say that something is,
如果它向我跑来，我就跑开。是的。所以当涉及到恶心时，思想和身体之间似乎存在一种联系。你说恶心的逻辑也会溢出到我们的社会和道德思考中。所以如果一个道德上不纯洁的人接触了神圣的东西，那个纯洁的东西现在就被视为被玷污或亵渎了。恶心似乎融入我们社会生活的方式有几种。一种方式是，如果我们描述或感觉或说某事是，
disgusting or show it as disgusting, then it can have real social consequences, as with my friend in the fifth grade. So there, the low-level visceral disgust actually caused me to have this more complex judgment and behavior of ostracizing, of not including him in things. And then there's this other way that perhaps is a bit more metaphorical, which is that we like to divide the world into clean and dirty. And the metaphor of good things being pure, being clean, is such that we feel that they can be tainted. So when something evil, when something bad
恶心的，或者表现出它是恶心的，那么它就会产生真正的社会后果，就像我五年级的朋友一样。所以在那儿，低水平的本能恶心实际上导致我有了这种更复杂的排斥、不让他参与事情的判断和行为。然后还有另一种方式，也许更隐喻一些，那就是我们喜欢把世界分为干净和肮脏。好东西是纯洁的、干净的隐喻是这样的，我们觉得它们会被玷污。所以当邪恶的东西，当坏的东西，
and something morally disgusting, taints those good things, it plays a very similar role as the cockroach in your soup. I mean, this is when you think about a phrase like cleanliness is next to godliness, in some ways, that's the same idea here. That's right. That's right. There is a biological necessity for us to keep our bodies fairly clean. You know, disease was one of the biggest threats to our lives throughout human history. So it's no wonder that not only evolution would give us all of these mechanisms to avoid getting sick, like an immune system,
和道德上令人恶心的东西，玷污了那些好东西时，它扮演的角色与你汤里的蟑螂非常相似。我的意思是，当你想到“清洁仅次于虔诚”这样的短语时，在某种程度上，这就是这里的同一个想法。没错。没错。我们保持身体相当干净是一种生物学上的必要。你知道，疾病是人类历史上对我们生命最大的威胁之一。所以难怪进化不仅会给我们所有这些避免生病的机制，比如免疫系统，
and an emotion like disgust, but that cultures would emphasize the importance of cleanliness and that we would use metaphors like cleanliness to start meaning things like keeping your spirit or your soul clean. I understand that you grew up in a religious environment. Did you hear language like this growing up? I did. I think I had a double dose of this
和像恶心这样的情绪，而且文化会强调清洁的重要性，我们会使用像清洁这样的隐喻来开始意味着保持你的精神或灵魂清洁。我了解到你在一个宗教环境中长大。你成长过程中听到过这样的语言吗？我听过。我想我对此有双重剂量，
because I grew up in a very conservative Christian household and so concepts of purity were important and ingrained in us. But I think I also happened to grow up in a household where disgust as an emotion was a very common emotion. I would characterize my family as being very disgust sensitive, as some researchers call it. That is simply they find the emotion of disgust to be a very easy one to have. And so in my household, if you did something dirty, you were not only chided for it, but that face that you described earlier, that wrinkled nose, that look of disgusted disapproval was a common one to receive. You've studied the relationship between disgust and homophobia. Tell me what the connection is here, David.
因为我在一个非常保守的基督教家庭长大，所以纯洁的概念很重要，并根植于我们心中。但我认为我也碰巧在一个恶心作为一种情绪是非常常见的情绪的家庭中长大。我会把我的家庭描述为对恶心非常敏感，正如一些研究人员所称的那样。也就是说，他们发现恶心的情绪是一种非常容易产生的情绪。所以在我家里，如果你做了什么肮脏的事，你不仅会因此受到责备，而且你之前描述的那种脸，那种皱起的鼻子，那种恶心的不赞成的表情，是经常收到的。你研究过恶心与恐同症之间的关系。告诉我这里的联系是什么，大卫。
Yeah, there's an interesting feature about disgust, which is that it is very easily tied to some. sex and sexuality. Now, this shouldn't be so surprising. Sex and sexuality and acts involved in sexual reproduction are quite risky, right? They involve bodies. They involve fluids. These are the kinds of things that we can become easily disgusted by because they're dangerous. So the domain of sexuality is one of the domains in which disgust seems to be extra powerful. In early research, when we were studying individual differences in disgust sensitivity, right? And so in how easily people got disgusted, what we found was that people who reported being easily disgusted in a number of different ways.
是的，关于恶心有一个有趣的特征，那就是它很容易与性行为和性取向联系在一起。现在，这不应该那么令人惊讶。性、性取向以及涉及有性生殖的行为风险很大，对吧？它们涉及身体。它们涉及体液。这些是我们容易感到恶心的东西，因为它们很危险。所以性领域是恶心似乎特别强大的领域之一。在早期的研究中，当我们研究个体在恶心敏感度上的差异时，对吧？以及人们有多容易感到恶心，我们发现那些报告在许多不同方面容易感到恶心的人。
So take all the examples that we've used so far, and imagine that I gave you a scale. I asked you, how disgusted would you be in this example or in this example? And I give you a score. Some people score very high, and some people would score very low. Most of us would be somewhere in the middle. Well, it turns out that the people who are more easily disgusted seem to have more anti-gay attitudes. That is, they're more homophobic. Why would same-sex relationships historically trigger more disgust than opposite sex relationships?
所以拿我们目前为止使用的所有例子，想象我给了你一个量表。我问你，在这个例子或那个例子中你会感到多恶心？然后我给你一个分数。有些人得分很高，有些人得分很低。我们大多数人会在中间某个地方。好吧，事实证明，那些更容易感到恶心的人似乎有更多的反同性恋态度。也就是说，他们更恐同。为什么同性关系在历史上比异性关系更容易引发恶心？
At a fundamental level, they all involve, you know, biology and body parts and swapping fluids, as you said. Yeah, and Chankar, I think you're onto something important that they probably would all of those sexual acts and relationships at some level could easily trigger disgust in us. If I were to just give you an example of any two people you didn't know having sex, you might feel disgust. I think the interesting thing about its role in homophobia or in anti-gay rhetoric is that, Because most people are not gay, it is very easy to have that emotion elicited because you can think of that as not the kind of sex that I would have. So in some ways, I think we can start to see why disgust would be such a potent force in politics and public life. It acts on us at a subterranean level. It shapes what we think is right and wrong.
在基本层面上，它们都涉及，你知道，生物学和身体部位以及交换体液，正如你所说。是的，尚卡尔，我认为你触及了一些重要的东西，即它们可能在某种程度上，所有那些性行为和关系在某种程度上都很容易在我们心中引发恶心。如果我只是给你举任何两个你不认识的人发生性关系的例子，你可能会感到恶心。我认为关于它在恐同症或反同性恋言论中的作用，有趣的事情是，因为大多数人不是同性恋，所以那种情绪很容易被激发，因为你可以认为那不是我会有的那种性行为。所以从某种程度上说，我认为我们可以开始明白为什么恶心在政治和公共生活中会成为如此强大的力量。它在潜意识层面作用于我们。它塑造了我们认为什么是对的，什么是错的。
I mean, you can see why it would be powerful. Yeah, and putting some of these things together, we can start seeing, in fact, why people would use it to great effect. So, one, it seems as if this is an emotion that is universal that everybody has. Two, it works through this process of contagion and contamination, and it's very easy to elicit. So one of the very easy things that we can do is, say, I want to convince you that a particular group of people or a particular individual or maybe even a certain act is wrong that you should avoid it, that you should dislike it. I can point out something that I think is disgusting about it. Maybe it can even invent it, right? Like the Haitian immigrants eating cats and dogs. Now,
我的意思是，你可以明白为什么它会很强大。是的，把其中一些东西放在一起，我们实际上可以开始明白为什么人们会有效地利用它。所以，第一，这似乎是一种每个人都有的普遍情绪。第二，它通过这种传染和污染的过程起作用，而且很容易被激发。所以我们可以做的非常简单的事情之一是，说，我想让你相信特定的一群人或特定的个人，甚至可能是某种行为是错误的，你应该避免它，你应该不喜欢它。我可以指出我认为关于它令人恶心的东西。也许它甚至可以发明它，对吧？就像海地移民吃猫狗一样。现在，
through the process of contagion, of contamination, I've linked a disgusting idea to a group of people or to a person. And because of that, it becomes like a very powerful tool in social political rhetoric to get us to dislike or disfavor or disrespect others. And again, when you think about the story about the Haitian immigrants, debunking the story can debunk it at the level of factual information. So I can tell myself, I don't really believe that story is true. I don't think it actually happened.
通过传染、污染的过程，我把一个令人恶心的想法与一群人或一个人联系起来。正因为如此，它在社会政治修辞中成为了一种非常强大的工具，让我们去不喜欢、不赞成或不尊重他人。再说一次，当你想到关于海地移民的故事时，揭穿这个故事可以在事实信息的层面上揭穿它。所以我可以告诉自己，我不真的相信那个故事是真的。我不认为它真的发生了。
But it's a part of me that it's still recorded. at the idea of people eating dogs and cats. And in some ways, my rational thought process is not able to obliterate that emotional reaction. That's right. You can't just undo the influence of emotions. If you could, it would be very nice to just tell people, oh, actually, ignore that thing that you just felt. And if we could do that, I think our lives would be very different. I understand that researchers have looked at how disgust shapes outcomes in the criminal justice system.
但它是我的一部分，它仍然对人们吃猫狗的想法感到恶心。在某种程度上，我的理性思维过程无法抹去那种情绪反应。没错。你不能仅仅撤销情绪的影响。如果你能，告诉人们“哦，实际上，忽略你刚才感觉到的那件事”会非常好。如果我们能做到这一点，我认为我们的生活会大不相同。我了解到研究人员已经研究了恶心如何塑造刑事司法系统中的结果。
When a crime is particularly disgusting, it can change the way we think about the criminal. Yeah, and this is one of the areas where there is just direct concern about biasing, right? So it may be that we want to defend our opinions about whether or not somebody should be engaged in some disgusting acts. But in a criminal system where imagine that there is a defendant who you do not know if they are guilty or not guilty. And now I'm asking you to make that judgment. Is this person guilty or not? And I show you or describe to you a fairly disgusting criminal act. Turns out that that disgust tends to bias people in favor of finding somebody guilty. In other words, the fact that the details of the crime,
当犯罪特别令人恶心时，它会改变我们对罪犯的看法。是的，这是直接担心偏见的领域之一，对吧？所以可能我们想捍卫我们关于某人是否应该从事某些令人恶心的行为的意见。但在一个刑事系统中，想象有一个被告，你不知道他们是否有罪。现在我要求你做出那个判断。这个人有罪吗？我向你展示或描述一个相当令人恶心的犯罪行为。事实证明，那种恶心往往会使人们偏向于认定某人有罪。换句话说，犯罪的细节，
were disgusting, predisposes me to think that the person being accused of the crime probably is guilty. That's right. There have been studies done just like this, where, for instance, they will show, these are in mock jury studies, or a common methodology used to study the psychology and the law. You bring people in and you present, you make it as if they were jurors in a trial. And some of the people are given images that are in black and white. of, say, a grisly crime scene, a murder scene.
是令人恶心的，这使我倾向于认为被指控犯罪的人很可能是有罪的。没错。已经进行了像这样的研究，例如，他们会展示，这些是在模拟陪审团研究中，或者研究心理学和法律的常用方法。你把人们带进来，你呈现，你让它看起来好像他们是审判中的陪审员。有些人被给予黑白图像。比如，一个可怕的犯罪现场，一个谋杀现场。
And some people are given those same images. In other words, the information is all the same, the same crime scene, but some people receive it in very vivid color. Those color images are much more disgusting to look at. And it turns out that just manipulating whether or not they see the images in color or in black and white increases, they're discussed, and this leads them to be more likely to find the defendant guilty, and in civil cases, more likely to actually give more damages. And if that's not an irrational effect of disgust, I don't quite know what is.
有些人被给予同样的图像。换句话说，信息都是一样的，同样的犯罪现场，但有些人以非常生动的彩色接收它。那些彩色图像看起来更令人恶心。事实证明，仅仅操纵他们是否以彩色或黑白观看图像就会增加他们的恶心感，这导致他们更有可能认定被告有罪，在民事案件中，更有可能实际上给予更多的赔偿。如果这不是恶心的非理性影响，我不知道什么才是。
When we come back, the politics have discussed, how it's being used to influence you, and what you can do about it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Listen to any political debate, and certain words seem to repeat themselves. Deplorable. Disgusting. Sickening. These aren't just insults. They point to something deeper. They point to the powerful psychology of disgust. Disgust is not only about rotten food, bad smells, and festering wounds.
回来后，恶心的政治，它如何被用来影响你，以及你能对此做些什么。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。听任何政治辩论，某些词似乎都在重复。可悲的。令人恶心的。令人作呕的。这些不仅仅是侮辱。它们指向更深层的东西。它们指向恶心的强大心理学。恶心不仅关于腐烂的食物、难闻的气味和溃烂的伤口。
It plays a role in how we think about our values. It shapes whom we trust, whom we fear, and what we think is wrong. If you have a personal story about disgust and how it has shaped your life or a follow-up question or comment about today's episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty.
它在我们思考价值观的方式中扮演着角色。它塑造了我们信任谁，我们害怕谁，以及我们认为什么是错的。如果你有一个关于恶心以及它如何塑造你生活的个人故事，或者关于今天这一集的后续问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制一个语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。
Then email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, disgust. At Cornell University, psychologist David Pizarro studies the intersection of disgust and ethics. He explores how our sensitivity to disgust influences our moral judgments and how that can be manipulated to shape our political views. David, you say that there's a long history of disgust being used to promote political propaganda. Tell me how it was used in the run-up to World War II and during the
然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“恶心”。在康奈尔大学，心理学家大卫·皮萨罗研究恶心与伦理的交叉点。他探索我们对恶心的敏感度如何影响我们的道德判断，以及这如何被操纵以塑造我们的政治观点。大卫，你说恶心被用来促进政治宣传有着悠久的历史。告诉我它是如何在二战前夕和期间被使用的，
Holocaust. Yeah. So it may come as no surprise to some of our listeners that disgusting images, was used by the Nazi party to make people feel a certain way about Jews, among other social groups. But it was a very common and powerful tactic to depict verbally or artistically depict a stereotypical Jew as dirty or filthy or greasy or slimy. And this was used to great effect. But it's language and imagery that predates Nazi Germany as well. So the philosopher Martha Nussbaum has pointed out that throughout lots and lots of recorded history, various groups, including women, gay people, Jews, are described as being disgusting in some way, as having some foulness or decay or smell, something to put. put us off and that this is as a rhetorical strategy, one that seems to work quite well. And of course, as we've seen, disgust in some ways can prompt us to want to get some distance
大屠杀。是的。所以对我们的一些听众来说，令人恶心的图像被纳粹党用来让人们对犹太人以及其他社会群体产生某种感觉，这可能并不奇怪。但描绘，口头或艺术地描绘一个刻板印象中的犹太人是肮脏的、污秽的、油腻的或黏糊糊的，这是一种非常普遍且强大的策略。这被非常有效地使用了。但这种语言和意象在纳粹德国之前也存在。所以哲学家玛莎·努斯鲍姆指出，在大量的记录历史中，各种群体，包括女性、同性恋者、犹太人，都被描述为在某种程度上是令人恶心的，具有某种污秽或腐烂或气味，有什么东西让人，让人反感，而这作为一种修辞策略，似乎工作得相当好。当然，正如我们所见，恶心在某种程度上可以促使我们想要保持一定的距离。
between us and the disgusting thing. But when you're applying disgust now to social groups, to individuals, to communities, that can also lead to ostracism. It can lead to prejudice. That's right. And here I think it's useful to compare and contrast to emotions, one of anger and one of disgust. Now, both of those can be used to great effect politically, right? If I'm angry at a group, I might engage and harm them, hurt them. But they're quite different in that one of them, as you just said, disgust motivates avoidance. So if I'm presented with something gross, I don't want to think about it. I want to avoid it. I don't want to see it. Anger, on the other hand, is what psychologists often refer to as an approach in motion.
在我们和令人作呕的事物之间。但当你现在将厌恶感应用于社会群体、个人或社区时，这也可能导致排斥。它可能导致偏见。没错。在这里，我认为比较和对比两种情绪是有益的，一种是愤怒，一种是厌恶。这两种情绪在政治上都可以产生巨大的影响，对吧？如果我对一个群体感到愤怒，我可能会去接触并伤害他们。但它们有很大的不同，正如你刚才所说，厌恶会促使回避。所以，如果我面对一些恶心的东西，我不想去想它。我想避开它。我不想看到它。另一方面，愤怒是心理学家常说的“趋近型情绪”。
Anger makes you want to engage with the target. Anger makes you want to do something in order to change what the state of affairs, to get revenge, for instance, or to find justice. Whereas disgust can lead you just to turn a blind eye. So if disgust shapes our judgments of others, it's easy to see how this can be a very potent political weapon. in. Can you predict people's political leanings, David, based on their sensitivity to disgust? We can. In fact, this is one of the first findings that we had that got us interested in studying
愤怒会让你想要与目标接触。愤怒会让你想要做点什么来改变现状，比如报复，或者寻求正义。而厌恶则可能导致你视而不见。因此，如果厌恶感塑造了我们对他人的判断，那么很容易看出这如何成为一种强有力的政治武器。大卫，你能根据人们对厌恶的敏感度来预测他们的政治倾向吗？我们可以。事实上，这是我们最早发现的、让我们对研究……
disgust and social judgment in general. We were studying this individual difference in disgust sensitivity. And one of the things that we kept finding was in the standard list of demographic questions that were usually included in such studies, we would also be. always have questions about political orientation. And what we found over and over again was that the more easily disgusted somebody said they were, the more likely they were to report being politically conservative. Now, I could say that just as easily the other way around. That is, the less easily discussed that someone is, the more likely they are to say that they're politically liberal, right? Because both of those things are true. And I don't want to imply that one is the
厌恶和社会判断产生兴趣的发现之一。我们当时正在研究这种个体在厌恶敏感度上的差异。我们不断发现的一件事是，在通常包含在此类研究中的标准人口统计学问题列表中，我们总是会询问政治倾向。我们反复发现的是，一个人说自己越容易感到厌恶，他们就越有可能报告自己是政治保守派。现在，我也可以同样容易地反过来说。也就是说，一个人越不容易感到厌恶，他们就越有可能说自己是政治自由派，对吧？因为这两者都是事实。我不想暗示其中一个是……
correct relationship and one is not. I'm wondering, is it possible that this is related or sits alongside the finding that people's sense of threat perception also shapes their political views. And again, you know, you can argue that it's good to have a high sense of threat perception. You can argue it's good to have a low sense of threat perception. But there have been studies that have indicated that people who are more easily threatened, who feel a greater sense of fear, are also more likely to be conservative, and people who have a lower sense of threat perception tend to be on the more liberal end of the spectrum.
正确的关系，而另一个不是。我想知道，这是否可能与人们的威胁感知感也会塑造他们的政治观点这一发现有关，或者与之并存。同样，你知道，你可以争辩说拥有高度的威胁感知感是件好事。你也可以争辩说拥有较低的威胁感知感是件好事。但已有研究表明，那些更容易感到威胁、感受到更大恐惧感的人，也更有可能是保守派；而那些威胁感知感较低的人，往往处于政治光谱中更自由的一端。
I think that's exactly right, and I think that's the right way to think about it. When you look at the research on this relationship between disgust and political orientation, you might ask, well, what aspects of political orientation specifically does this disgust predict well? And what it looks like it's most associated with is what we might call traditionalism, right? The view that the old ways are the good ways and that we should avoid anything too new and too fancy because status quo has gotten us to where we are.
我认为这完全正确，我认为这是思考这个问题的正确方式。当你审视关于厌恶与政治倾向之间关系的研究时，你可能会问，这种厌恶感具体能很好地预测政治倾向的哪些方面？它看起来与我们所说的“传统主义”最相关，对吧？即认为旧方式是好方式，我们应该避免任何太新、太花哨的东西，因为现状已经让我们走到了今天。
So let's not abandon that. And it seems as if that is very conceptually, if not psychologically, related to this general aversion. to threat because, after all, novel things are potential threats. And again, this is not necessarily, as you point out, making a value judgment about things, because in fact, novel things can be wonderful. They can lead you to new pastures or new opportunities, but they can also lead you to danger and to threat. Absolutely.
所以我们不要放弃这一点。这似乎在概念上，如果不是在心理上，与这种对威胁的普遍厌恶感有关，因为毕竟，新奇的事物是潜在的威胁。同样，正如你指出的那样，这并不一定是对事物做出价值判断，因为事实上，新奇的事物可能是美妙的。它们可以带你走向新的牧场或新的机遇，但它们也可能带你走向危险和威胁。绝对是这样。
And I think just a moment's reflection shows that both of those orientations that of pursuing the novel and that of being wary of the novel are very very. important to have and whether one of them will be successful is completely dependent upon what environment you happen to be in. You've actually tested the effectiveness of disgust as a tool in persuasion, and in one study you were able to manipulate people's views by changing the smell in a room? Yes, that's right. So one of the most powerful, easy ways of inducing disgust is through the use of a smell.
我认为只要反思一下就会发现，追求新奇和对新奇保持警惕这两种取向都非常非常重要，而其中哪一种会成功，完全取决于你所处的环境。你实际上测试了厌恶作为一种说服工具的有效性，在一项研究中，你通过改变房间里的气味来操纵人们的观点？是的，没错。所以，诱发厌恶感最强大、最简单的方法之一就是通过气味。
A smell is nice because I don't have to tell people a story. I can show images, but those images usually contain some information. But a smell is a powerful direct path to feeling disgust often. And what we found was that when we gave people a set of questionnaires that included among them, questions about how individuals felt about various social groups, including gay men and lesbian, women. When those individuals were completing those questionnaires in a room that smelled bad, they were more negative in their evaluations of those social groups. You ran another study where you reminded people about the importance of physical cleanliness.
气味很好，因为我不必给人们讲故事。我可以展示图片，但这些图片通常包含一些信息。但气味是通往厌恶感的强大直接途径。我们发现，当我们给人们一套问卷，其中包含关于个人对各种社会群体（包括男同性恋者和女同性恋者）的看法的问题时，当这些人在一个气味难闻的房间里完成这些问卷时，他们对这些社会群体的评价更为负面。你还进行了另一项研究，提醒人们注意身体清洁的重要性。
What was the effect of doing this? This study, I think, shows the principle of what we've been talking about well. because in this study that you just referred to, we reminded people that they should wash their hands to keep clean. Now, this wasn't a manipulation of disgust, right? These other things that I've been talking about, like a foul odor or measuring people's tendency to experience disgust, those are clearly discussed.
这样做有什么效果？我认为这项研究很好地展示了我们一直在讨论的原则。因为在你刚才提到的这项研究中，我们提醒人们应该洗手以保持清洁。这并不是对厌恶感的操纵，对吧？我刚才提到的其他事情，比如恶臭或测量人们体验厌恶的倾向，那些显然是厌恶。
But we were interested in this broader theory about what disgust might be doing, that it might be increasing your feelings of threat, about disease, about pathogens, that specific kind of threat in the world around you. And one way we thought you might also get this is by reminding people that there's disease in the world. And so this was a study where we told people, hey, this was a time many years ago before COVID when the swine flu was the thing that people were afraid of. So simply reminding people to wash their hands seemed to make them actually at least temporarily ramp up how
但我们对这个关于厌恶可能在起什么作用的更广泛的理论感兴趣，即它可能会增加你对威胁、对疾病、对病原体的感觉，即你周围世界中那种特定的威胁。我们认为你可能获得这种感觉的一种方式是提醒人们世界上存在疾病。所以这是一项研究，我们告诉人们，嘿，这是多年前在新冠疫情之前，当时猪流感是人们害怕的东西。所以仅仅提醒人们洗手似乎就让他们实际上至少暂时提高了他们报告的政治保守程度。
conservative politically they reported being. Let's talk about how this plays out in the actual world of politics. We've seen some examples of how disgust can be used in propaganda, but I'm curious. Do you see disgust at work in current political debates around the world, David? It's hard not to. I mean, so maybe part of the problem is that whenever somebody makes a remark about the disgustingness of somebody else in a political context, that gets sent to me. But I seem to hear it a lot, right?
让我们谈谈这在现实政治世界中是如何体现的。我们已经看到了一些厌恶感如何在宣传中被使用的例子，但我很好奇。大卫，你在世界当前的政治辩论中看到了厌恶感在起作用吗？很难不看到。我的意思是，也许部分问题在于，每当有人在政治背景下对别人的令人作呕发表评论时，那就会被发给我。但我似乎经常听到它，对吧？
I seem to hear, I think our current president is quite fond of the disgusting imagery. And I think he's quite savvy in this way. But whenever there is a discussion of outgroups, whenever there is a discussion of, say, immigration, I find that there's often this language that appeals to both the threat, the physical fear that people might have, but also to the, to perhaps this threat is also from the fact that they're kind of gross. In 2015, the conservative journalist Megan Kelly moderated one of the presidential debates between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton. Donald Trump didn't like the questions the moderator
我似乎听到，我认为我们现任总统非常喜欢令人作呕的意象。我认为他在这一点上非常精明。但每当有关于外群体的讨论，每当有关于，比如说，移民的讨论时，我发现经常会有这种语言，它既诉诸于威胁，即人们可能有的身体恐惧，也诉诸于，也许这种威胁也来自于他们有点恶心的事实。2015年，保守派记者梅根·凯利主持了唐纳德·特朗普和希拉里·克林顿之间的一场总统辩论。唐纳德·特朗普不喜欢主持人……
was asking. Here's how he later described Megan Kelly. She gets out and she starts asking me all sorts of ridiculous. questions. And, you know, you can see there was blood coming out of her eyes, blood coming out of her wherever. Now, it's possible that Donald Trump was merely misspeaking, David, but he didn't stop to revise or correct that remark. And some commentators took it to be a reference to menstruation and an attempt in some ways to paint his interlocutor as disgusting. Yeah, if it was, if he misspoke, I think it was clear that he sort of doubled down on it. because I read it in the same way.
提出的问题。以下是他后来描述梅根·凯利的方式。她走出来，开始问我各种荒谬的问题。而且，你知道，你可以看到她的眼睛里有血流出来，她的任何地方都有血流出来。现在，大卫，唐纳德·特朗普可能只是口误，但他并没有停下来修改或纠正那个言论。一些评论员认为这是指月经，在某种程度上试图将他的对话者描绘成令人作呕的。是的，如果真是这样，如果他口误了，我认为很明显他某种程度上加倍坚持了这一点。因为我也是这样解读的。
And again, I'll just point back to the philosopher Martha Nussbaum, who was one of the first people I read to point out that the emotion of disgust has been associated with various groups, but women in particular. And menstruation, especially for men, is something that it's not difficult to elicit disgust. You can find countless examples dating back to the earliest written word of how women are treated while they are menstruating. And so this was in some ways, unfortunately, low-hanging fruit for somebody like Donald Trump. So stay with this idea for just a second more. We discuss this a little bit in the context of same-sex relationships, because, of course, opposite-sex relationships often have some of the same-biological characteristics as same-sex relationships.
同样，我只想指出哲学家玛莎·努斯鲍姆，她是我读到的第一批指出厌恶情绪与各种群体，特别是女性相关联的人之一。而月经，尤其是对男性来说，是很难不引起厌恶的事情。你可以找到无数追溯到最早文字记录的例子，说明女性在月经期间是如何被对待的。所以这在某种程度上，不幸的是，对于像唐纳德·特朗普这样的人来说是唾手可得的果实。所以在这个想法上再停留一秒钟。我们在同性关系的背景下讨论过这一点，因为当然，异性关系通常与同性关系具有一些相同的生物学特征。
relationships. And the same is true for men and women. I mean, men have bodies. They have biologies. You could argue some things that men do or that happen to men can be disgusting. Why is it that menstruation has come to be seen as disgusting in a way that many male bodily functions have not? Well, there you're asking a very important question. And I believe that I'm probably not the most qualified to speak on this, but what I can say is that any of this discussion will always be colored by the society, the power structures that we currently inhabit. And the fact that men might be the ones in power to specifically describe the bodily functions of women and make us feel disgust, targeting other men as the audience, probably has something to do with it.
关系。男性和女性也是如此。我的意思是，男性有身体。他们有生物学特征。你可以争辩说男性所做的一些事情或发生在男性身上的事情可能是令人作呕的。为什么月经会被视为令人作呕，而许多男性身体功能却没有？嗯，你问了一个非常重要的问题。我相信我可能不是最有资格谈论这一点的人，但我能说的是，所有这些讨论都将始终受到我们目前所处的社会、权力结构的渲染。事实上，男性可能是那些有权专门描述女性身体功能并让我们感到厌恶的人，以其他男性为受众，这可能与此有关。
It is striking, though, the point that you're making, David, which is if we look down history, you know, the Nazis found the Jews disgusting. You know, upper caste people in India can find lower caste people disgusting. You know, men can find women disgusting. And it's no accident that it's the group that's often in the majority or the group that's in power that ascribes, you know, aspects of disgust to the group that's in the minority or the group that doesn't have power. That's right, Shankar. And as you point out, I mean, even in talking about, say, the caste system, but throughout various parts of the world, the people who might be lower in power are usually the ones who have to do the more disgusting jobs. So you're getting sort of a doubling of the
不过，大卫，你提出的观点很引人注目，那就是如果我们回顾历史，你知道，纳粹觉得犹太人令人作呕。你知道，印度的种姓制度高层人士会觉得低种姓的人令人作呕。你知道，男性会觉得女性令人作呕。而且，通常是多数群体或掌权群体将厌恶的方面归咎于少数群体或没有权力的群体，这绝非偶然。没错，尚卡尔。正如你指出的那样，我的意思是，即使在谈论，比如说，种姓制度时，但在世界各地，权力较低的人通常是那些必须做更令人作呕的工作的人。所以你得到了一种双重效应。
effect. One thing that jumps out at me, David, is that when someone accuses you of being disgust, it's almost impossible to respond to that. I mean, you can respond to an accusation about, you know, malfeasance or corruption or incompetence, and you can point to evidence that basically says, no, no, that's not true. But disgust has this way of, in some ways, persuading people so powerfully
有一件事让我很吃惊，大卫，那就是当有人指责你令人作呕时，几乎不可能对此做出回应。我的意思是，你可以回应关于，你知道，渎职、腐败或无能的指责，你可以指出证据，基本上说，不，不，那不是真的。但厌恶感有一种方式，在某些方面，如此有力地说服人们……
that you can't really mount an argument against it, because as we've just seen, the argument in some ways is sort of helpless in the face of the emotion. Yeah, that's a very good point. And I think part of it has to do with this power of negativity that you referred to in Rosen's work where, you know, how much soup can you pour on a cockroach to make the cockroach clean? It's not going to happen. Part of it is that some of these things just are true. We are all disgusting. We are all bodies.
以至于你无法真正提出反对它的论点，因为正如我们刚才所看到的，在某种程度上，这种论点在面对这种情绪时是无助的。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我认为部分原因与你提到的罗森作品中提到的消极力量有关，你知道，你能在蟑螂身上倒多少汤才能让蟑螂变干净？那是不可能的。部分原因是其中一些事情确实是真的。我们都很恶心。我们都是身体。
We are all tainted by the fact that we are humans in these bodies. And so there's very little we can do to argue our way out of that. And it really does seem like because it bypasses our rational faculties often, there's nothing our rational faculties can really do to undo it. If somebody said something gross about me, you may never be able to shake that thought from your head when you meet with me. And so the best we can do is perhaps try to just be, be aware that this might happen?
我们都因为我们是拥有这些身体的人类这一事实而被玷污了。所以我们几乎没有什么办法能争辩摆脱这一点。而且它确实看起来，因为它经常绕过我们的理性能力，我们的理性能力真的无法做任何事情来消除它。如果有人对我说了什么恶心的话，当你见到我时，你可能永远无法从脑海中挥去那个想法。所以我们能做的最好的事情也许就是试着去，去意识到这可能会发生？
When we come back, when we should push back against our feelings of disgust, and how to do that. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Disgust is thought to be an emotion that evolved to protect us from harm. But like all emotions, it can be just as misleading
当我们回来时，我们什么时候应该抵制我们的厌恶感，以及如何做到这一点。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。厌恶被认为是一种为了保护我们免受伤害而进化的情绪。但像所有情绪一样，它可能既具有误导性……
as it is helpful. At Cornell University, psychologist David Pizarro explores how disgust can cloud our judgment and how other emotions can sometimes override its influence. David, when it comes to the deployment of disgust in politics and public life, how should we deal with it? Are there ways that we can inoculate ourselves against disgust? Should we be doing that? Yeah, it's a tricky question, but I think a very, a very important one. So some have argued that we should listen to our disgust response more.
又很有帮助。在康奈尔大学，心理学家大卫·皮萨罗探索了厌恶感如何模糊我们的判断，以及其他情绪有时如何覆盖其影响。大卫，当谈到厌恶感在政治和公共生活中的部署时，我们应该如何处理它？有没有办法让我们自己对厌恶感产生免疫？我们应该这样做吗？是的，这是一个棘手的问题，但我认为这是一个非常、非常重要的问题。所以有些人认为我们应该更多地倾听我们的厌恶反应。
So the bioethicist Leon Kass famously argued that there was wisdom in repugnance. And he believed that we should pay attention because this emotion was informative. It was telling us something that might be wrong. If I'm grossed out by the thing that you do, maybe it is wrong that you do that. others like martin nussbaum have said no this in fact is quite a dangerous way of thinking about things because you could pretty much argue that anybody or anything is wrong or bad by pointing out something disgusting um i do think personally that one of the things that has brought value to me in studying this uh this topic is that at the very least if I am being influenced by disgust to believe that a certain thing or person is wrong, I want to be a bit more reflective about it because I'll give you an example. So I have a friend who's a philosopher who has said to me,
所以生物伦理学家莱昂·卡斯曾著名地提出，厌恶中蕴含着智慧。他认为我们应该注意，因为这种情绪是有信息量的。它在告诉我们一些可能错误的事情。如果我对你所做的事情感到恶心，也许你这样做是错误的。其他人，如玛莎·努斯鲍姆，则表示不，这实际上是一种非常危险的思考方式，因为你可以通过指出令人作呕的事情，几乎可以争辩说任何人或任何事情都是错误或糟糕的。嗯，我个人确实认为，研究这个话题给我带来的价值之一是，至少如果我受到厌恶感的影响而认为某件事或某个人是错误的，我想对此进行更多的反思，因为我会给你举个例子。所以我有一个哲学家朋友，他曾对我说，
well, what about somebody who engages in the sexual abuse of young children? That's a disgusting thing. Are you telling me that I should, for some reason, turn off my disgust, shouldn't I amplify, shouldn't this motivate me to bring that person to justice? To which I guess my response would be, if disgust is the only thing making you want to bring this person to justice, then I'm not sure you're doing it the right way, right? I think that there are other grounds for finding fault in people. Let's get back to the jurors. I think that, that there are facts of the matter that should lead you to decide whether somebody is guilty or not of committing a crime.
嗯，那些对幼儿进行性虐待的人呢？那是一件令人作呕的事情。你是在告诉我，我应该因为某种原因关闭我的厌恶感吗？我不应该放大它吗？这不应该激励我将那个人绳之以法吗？对此我的回答是，如果厌恶感是唯一让你想要将此人绳之以法的东西，那么我不确定你这样做的方式是对的，对吧？我认为还有其他理由可以发现人们的过错。让我们回到陪审员身上。我认为，有事实依据应该引导你决定某人是否有罪。
And that the disgust probably shouldn't play a role in that judgment. And so I think there's other information that's more relevant when we're making judgments that are so critical to our social lives. Some of this has to do with how we're going to vote on whether men can marry other men, right? We don't want to just be guided by whatever repulsion we might have when thinking about sexual acts. I'm wondering how your own views have evolved when it comes to questions of disgust and public policy, David. You know, as somebody who was raised quite religious, and unfortunately in a community that was quite homophobic, as a younger man, and I'm, embarrassed to admit this, but I think it's important to admit, I was quite homophobic. I believed that men shouldn't marry men. And I also believed that it was disgusting that they did.
而厌恶感可能不应该在那个判断中发挥作用。所以我认为当我们做出对我们的社会生活如此关键的判断时，还有其他信息更相关。其中一些与我们将如何投票决定男性是否可以与男性结婚有关，对吧？我们不想仅仅被我们在思考性行为时可能产生的任何排斥感所引导。大卫，我想知道你自己在厌恶和公共政策问题上的观点是如何演变的。你知道，作为一个在相当宗教的家庭中长大的人，不幸的是，在一个相当恐同的社区中，作为一个年轻人，我很尴尬地承认这一点，但我认为承认这一点很重要，我曾经相当恐同。我相信男性不应该与男性结婚。而且我也相信他们这样做是令人作呕的。
And over time, my views changed. But I'll tell you, the views, the moral views, my reasoned views evolved before my emotions did. And I just, you know, I don't know how else to say it other than I just became convinced for other reasons that some things were right or wrong. And I'm sort of repulsed by my previous views on this matter. But I do know that for a long time, I still let disgust influence my judgments at an individual level to a greater degree that I wanted. So if I had to map out my own trajectory,
随着时间的推移，我的观点改变了。但我告诉你，这些观点，道德观点，我理性的观点在我的情绪之前就演变了。我只是，你知道，我不知道除了说我只是因为其他原因确信某些事情是对的还是错的之外，还能怎么说。而且我对我在这个问题上的先前观点感到厌恶。但我确实知道，在很长一段时间里，我仍然让厌恶感在个人层面上影响我的判断，程度超过了我的意愿。所以如果我必须规划我自己的轨迹，
it doesn't, not to make it seem like I've moved from this intuitive moral monster driven by disgust to this perfectly rational being. Right. I hope that, I hope it doesn't come across that way. But what I have tried to do is to find ways to arrive at my moral views that I can count on as being reliable, as being ones that can convince others, is being ones that at least somebody can defend themselves from, unlike what you were saying about.
这并不，不是为了让它看起来像我已经从这个被厌恶感驱动的直觉道德怪物变成了这个完全理性的存在。对。我希望，我希望它不会给人留下那种印象。但我所尝试做的是找到方法来得出我可以信赖的道德观点，作为可靠的观点，作为可以说服他人的观点，作为至少某人可以为自己辩护的观点，不像你所说的关于……
If somebody labels you gross, what are you going to do? What can you say to that? And in some ways, it might actually be really important for us to police, you know, our own views or things that feel intuitively right to us. So if you're a liberal, for example, you might be horrified when Donald Trump says that immigrants in Ohio are eating dogs and cats, and you think this is very unfair. But you might have a little chuckle when you see the balloon featuring diaper dawn and showing Donald Trump in a diaper. And again, what that really shows is that many of us are perfectly willing to be two-faced about this,
如果有人给你贴上恶心的标签，你打算怎么办？你能说什么？在某些方面，我们警察，你知道，我们自己的观点或我们直觉上觉得正确的事情，实际上可能非常重要。所以如果你是一个自由派，例如，当唐纳德·特朗普说俄亥俄州的移民在吃狗和猫时，你可能会感到震惊，你认为这非常不公平。但当你看到那个以“尿布唐”为特色的气球，展示唐纳德·特朗普穿着尿布时，你可能会轻笑一下。同样，这真正表明的是，我们许多人完全愿意在这方面两面派，
that we are upset about the deployment of disgust when it harms our interests, but we're perfectly willing to do it if it advances our goals. Absolutely, and I'm glad that you're saying this because I think that it is quite easy to fall into the trap of as a personally as a liberal of thinking that, oh, I am beyond this, but I see conservatives doing it all the time. That's just untrue, right? So it should not matter whether or not the president is wearing diapers or whatever, right? the personal biological functions of the president should not matter when it comes to me judging his policies. And it's unfortunate, but it is very easy to fall into this sort of double standard and this hypocrisy. One of the interesting findings that you and others have noticed is that love and lust can eliminate or ameliorate feelings of disgust.
当厌恶感的部署损害我们的利益时，我们感到不安，但如果它推进了我们的目标，我们完全愿意这样做。绝对是这样，我很高兴你这么说，因为我认为作为一个自由派，很容易陷入认为“哦，我超越了这一点，但我看到保守派一直在这样做”的陷阱。那是不真实的，对吧？所以总统是否穿着尿布或其他什么并不重要，对吧？当我在评判他的政策时，总统个人的生物功能不应该重要。不幸的是，很容易陷入这种双重标准和虚伪。你和其他人注意到的一个有趣的发现是，爱和欲望可以消除或改善厌恶感。
How so, David? this is one of the more fascinating things about disgust so because disgust is about bodies and bodies are dangerous things with various fluids emanating from them that might make you sick it's very easy to feel disgust at other human beings but there are a few things that we have to do as a species one we have to take care of our young right and that involves as any parent knows or as any older sibling might know, changing diapers. And it turns out that changing diapers is much easier when it's your child than when it's somebody else's, even though the contents of that diaper might be identical. And so there is something about love that seems to turn off that disgust.
怎么会这样，大卫？这是关于厌恶感最迷人的事情之一，因为厌恶感是关于身体的，而身体是危险的东西，有各种液体从中散发出来，可能会让你生病，所以很容易对其他人感到厌恶。但作为一个物种，我们必须做几件事，一，我们必须照顾我们的后代，对吧？正如任何父母所知，或者任何年长的兄弟姐妹可能所知，这涉及更换尿布。事实证明，当它是你自己的孩子时，更换尿布比是别人的孩子时要容易得多，即使尿布里的内容物可能是一样的。所以爱似乎确实能关闭那种厌恶感。
And I think it wouldn't work if it weren't like that. And not just for our children, but for anybody we live with whom we love, that feeling of disgust just has to temporarily get set aside when we're dealing with them. And lust is a similar thing, right? If honestly, Shankar, if we had to think about what sex involved, we would probably be disgusted quite a lot and never engage in it. And that would be, that would not be good for our species. So what other researchers have shown is sexual arousal can temporarily mute the effects of disgust. So if you actually get people sexually aroused, they're less likely to be grossed out by something, even if that thing has nothing to do with the sex.
我认为如果不是这样的话，它就不会起作用。不仅对我们的孩子，而且对我们住在一起的任何我们所爱的人，当我们与他们打交道时，那种厌恶感就必须暂时被搁置。欲望也是类似的事情，对吧？老实说，尚卡尔，如果我们必须思考性涉及什么，我们可能会感到非常厌恶，永远不会参与其中。那将是，那对我们的物种来说是不好的。所以其他研究人员已经表明，性唤起可以暂时抑制厌恶感的影响。所以如果你真的让人产生性唤起，他们就不太可能对某事感到恶心，即使那件事与性无关。
By the same token, though, if they're disgusted first, they're less likely to be able to become sexually aroused. I'm wondering how thinking so much about disgust affects you personally, David, when you come home at the end of the day after inventing all kinds of new studies about disgust, are you still able to keep your dinner down? I genuinely have to not think about this stuff. I really do. And it is not difficult to make me lose my appetite. One of the reasons I believe that I started studying discussed to begin with was,
同样，如果他们先感到厌恶，他们就不太可能产生性唤起。大卫，我想知道思考这么多关于厌恶感的问题对你个人有什么影响，当你发明了各种关于厌恶感的新研究后，在一天结束时回到家，你还能吃得下晚饭吗？我真的必须不去想这些东西。我真的必须。而且让我失去食欲并不难。我相信我最初开始研究厌恶感的原因之一是，
of all the emotions, it seems like it's a pretty easy one to elicit in others. So it's kind of hard to make people sad or angry. You have to come up with some pretty in-depth manipulations. to make people feel these emotions. For a lot of people, one picture or even one word is enough to make them disgusted. And I'm from that ilk. I think that intuitively, I must have thought, the world is like me. So I will very easily discuss people.
在所有情绪中，它似乎是很容易在他人身上引起的一种。所以很难让人感到悲伤或愤怒。你必须想出一些非常深入的操纵手段来让人感到这些情绪。对很多人来说，一张图片甚至一个词就足以让他们感到厌恶。我就是那一类人。我想直觉上，我一定认为，世界和我一样。所以我很容易厌恶别人。
The downside is, to give you a concrete example, for many of the studies that I ran with my collaborator, a longtime collaborator on this, who was a graduate student here at Cornell, Yoel Imbar, for many of the studies that we ran on disgust, he had to pick all of the stimuli. He had to design the studies. I couldn't handle doing it. When I would give talks, I would pick the same two images that were disgusting because I had gotten used to those.
缺点是，给你举个具体的例子，对于我和我的合作者，一位在这里长期合作的研究生，乔尔·因巴尔，一起进行的许多研究，对于我们进行的许多关于厌恶的研究，他必须挑选所有的刺激物。他必须设计研究。我无法处理这些。当我做演讲时，我会挑选同样的两个令人作呕的图片，因为我已经习惯了那些。
So you can habituate, you know, you can get used to a specific image, but I could not get get rid of my general disgust. So you and your wife were recently looking at an online photo album of your daughter, and you noticed something about the photos, David. What was it? Well, I hope my daughter never hears this. Well, I had recently gotten a nicer camera, nicer than the phone cameras that I've been used to.
所以你可以习惯，你知道，你可以习惯一张特定的图片，但我无法摆脱我普遍的厌恶感。所以你和你的妻子最近在看你们女儿的在线相册，你注意到了照片的一些事情，大卫。是什么？嗯，我希望我女儿永远不要听到这个。嗯，我最近买了一个更好的相机，比我习惯使用的手机相机更好。
And we had been out taking pictures. of not just our child but others. There's a little outing with some friends from school. For context, my daughter is almost three years old. And when I saw pictures of my daughter in the cold with a snot dangling from her nose, my immediate thought was, how cute, what a beautiful young daughter I have. And then I saw, in that same role, I saw pictures of another child who objectively, I will admit, is a very, very beautiful young child.
我们一直在外面拍照。不仅是我们的孩子，还有其他人。这是和学校的一些朋友的一次小郊游。背景是，我女儿快三岁了。当我看到我女儿在寒冷中鼻子上挂着鼻涕的照片时，我立刻想到的是，多可爱，我有一个多么漂亮的小女儿。然后我看到，在同一卷里，我看到了另一个孩子的照片，我客观地承认，他是一个非常、非常漂亮的小孩。
They had snot dripping from their nose, and I wanted to gag. I thought, how could this mother not have wiped this boy's nose before we took the pictures? Talk about, you know, this is a much less politically charged instance of hypocrisy, but is one that I noticed in myself quite strongly. Do you have a personal story about disgust, or do you have a comment or question about this episode? If you'd be willing to share your question or comment or story with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty.
他们的鼻子上滴着鼻涕，我想作呕。我想，这个母亲怎么能在我们拍照前不擦掉这个男孩的鼻涕？谈论，你知道，这是一个政治色彩少得多的虚伪例子，但这是我在自己身上强烈注意到的一个例子。你有一个关于厌恶的个人故事吗？或者你对这一集有什么评论或问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的问题、评论或故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。
Then email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, disgust. When you think of all the yucky, disgusting things you have to do, the thing that might come most easily to mind are the times you had a plumbing disaster in your home. A backed up toilet isn't just a problem. It's a disgusting problem. Little wonder then that if we have to choose
然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“厌恶”。当你想到你必须做的所有令人讨厌、令人作呕的事情时，最容易想到的可能是你家里发生管道灾难的时候。堵塞的马桶不仅仅是一个问题。这是一个令人作呕的问题。难怪，如果我们必须选择……
between attending to a plumbing problem and focusing on something beautiful, most of us would prefer the latter. Some time ago, I spoke with Stanford's Huggie Rao about the tension between what he calls poetry and plumbing. He argues that in both our personal and professional lives, many of us ignore the plumbing to focus on the poetry. This may make short-term sense, but it invariably has long-term costs.
处理管道问题和专注于美好的事物，我们大多数人会更喜欢后者。前段时间，我与斯坦福大学的哈吉·拉奥谈到了他所谓的“诗歌”与“管道”之间的张力。他认为，在我们的个人和职业生活中，我们许多人忽视了管道，而去专注于诗歌。这在短期内可能是有意义的，但它总是会有长期的代价。
After we aired a recent episode with Huggy, many of you wrote in with accounts of the metaphorical plumbing challenges you've faced. We've asked Huggy to come back to the show to respond to those questions. When we come back, we get out our plungers, metaphorically speaking, and run your questions by Hagi Rao. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
在我们播出最近一集关于哈吉的节目后，你们许多人写信讲述了你们所面临的隐喻性的管道挑战。我们已经请哈吉回到节目中来回答这些问题。当我们回来时，我们将拿出我们的皮搋子，从隐喻的角度来说，并让哈吉·拉奥来回答你们的问题。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Before you move into a new home, you take a tour of the place. You imagine where the furniture will go. You daydream about cozy mornings in the breakfast nook. About kids playing in the living room. You picture parties you'll host with friends. Maybe the vegetables you'll grow in the garden. What you don't think about?
在你搬进新家之前，你会参观那个地方。你会想象家具会放在哪里。你会幻想在早餐角度过舒适的早晨。关于孩子们在客厅里玩耍。你会想象你将与朋友举办的派对。也许是你将在花园里种植的蔬菜。你没有想到的是？
All the chores needed to take care of the house, dusting the windowsills, cleaning mold in the shower, scraping burnt food off the bottom of the oven. And those are the small problems. You'll need to replace the water heater, retile the roof, and perhaps the worst headache, deal with plumbing disasters hidden deep behind the walls. At Stanford University, Hagi Rau argues that what is true of real estate is also true of our lives. If we want to be successful, we need to think less about the fun stuff and more about the plumbing. Hagi Rao recently joined us for an episode titled Why Following Your Dreams Isn't Enough.
照顾房子所需的所有家务，擦拭窗台，清洁淋浴间的霉菌，刮掉烤箱底部的烧焦食物。而这些只是小问题。你需要更换热水器，重新铺设屋顶，也许是最头疼的问题，处理隐藏在墙壁深处的管道灾难。在斯坦福大学，哈吉·拉奥认为，房地产的真理也适用于我们的生活。如果我们想成功，我们需要少想那些有趣的事情，多想管道。哈吉·拉奥最近参加了我们的一集节目，标题是《为什么追随你的梦想是不够的》。
If you miss that conversation, you can find it in this podcast feed. Today, Hagi joins us for our listener-driven segment, your questions answered. Hagi Rao, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you so very much, Shankar. It's a pleasure to rejoin the conversation. Hagi, in our initial conversation, we talked about a tension that affects many people and organizations, particularly as they're trying to launch a new endeavor. You described this tension as poetry versus plumbing. What do you mean by those terms? This wonderfully evocative metaphor of poetry versus plumbing goes back to my wonderful Stanford colleague and mentor James March.
如果你错过了那次对话，你可以在这个播客订阅源中找到它。今天，哈吉加入了我们的听众驱动环节，回答你们的问题。哈吉·拉奥，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。很高兴能重新加入对话。哈吉，在我们最初的对话中，我们谈到了影响许多人和组织的一种张力，特别是在他们试图启动一项新事业时。你将这种张力描述为诗歌与管道。你所说的这些术语是什么意思？这个关于诗歌与管道的奇妙而生动的隐喻可以追溯到我出色的斯坦福大学同事和导师詹姆斯·马奇。
What it means is poetry has to do with the domain of vision, aspirational, dreams. Plumbing has to do with the guts of execution, the guts of implementation. So that's the tension. How much do you emphasize vision and desirability? How much do you emphasize feasibility and execution? And so being able to do both and that kind of ambidexterity is so central for any leader. In our previous conversation, we discussed several examples of businesses and organizations that fail to pay attention to the plumbing. One that we didn't talk about is the company Theranos.
它的意思是，诗歌与愿景、抱负、梦想的领域有关。管道与执行的本质、实施的本质有关。这就是张力。你多强调愿景和可取性？你多强调可行性和执行力？所以能够两者兼顾，那种双元性对任何领导者来说都是如此核心。在我们之前的对话中，我们讨论了几个未能关注管道的企业和组织的例子。我们没有谈论的一个是Theranos公司。
You call it a perfect example of an organization that prioritized poetry over plumbing? Yes. That's a fascinating example, Shankar, because, you know, Teranos certainly had a compelling dream or a compelling vision, so to speak. and the vision was, how do you use one small fingerprick sample to do a galaxy of blood tests? It's a powerful vision. Unfortunately, what happened was while the vision was powerful, it was so seductive. In part, what happened is the founders and the employees fell victim to that vision without paying attention to the plumbing.
你称它为一个优先考虑诗歌而不是管道的组织的完美例子？是的。这是一个迷人的例子，尚卡尔，因为，你知道，Theranos当然有一个引人注目的梦想或引人注目的愿景，可以这么说。而愿景是，你如何使用一个小的指尖采血样本来进行大量的血液测试？这是一个强大的愿景。不幸的是，发生的事情是，虽然愿景很强大，但它太诱人了。在某种程度上，发生的事情是创始人和员工成为了那个愿景的受害者，而没有关注管道。
And here's kind of what I mean, because the... The premise of Theranos was, can we use how software is developed in software firms in Silicon Valley? Can we use the same development model for a medical device? And you can imagine how difficult that is. You know, when you develop new software, obviously they're going to be bugs and things that you haven't addressed. And you progressively improve them as users begin to use them. You can't do that with an FDA approved device. I mean, that needs to be pretty good before.
这就是我的意思，因为……Theranos的前提是，我们能否使用硅谷软件公司开发软件的方式？我们能否将同样的开发模型用于医疗设备？你可以想象这有多困难。你知道，当你开发新软件时，显然会有漏洞和你没有解决的事情。随着用户开始使用它们，你会逐步改进它们。你不能用FDA批准的设备这样做。我的意思是，那在它发布之前需要相当好。
it sort of goes out. So that was like a plumbing kind of tension right there. But the other thing is this vision, in a sense, led the founders to create a kind of culture of like almost no employee could voice concerns about plumbing. I mean, if you did, you faced a lawsuit, for example. And, you know, they had a board composed of diplomats and senior people like George Schulz and the others who were kind of far removed from the world of medical diagnostics. And you can imagine what happened. Employees couldn't blow the whistle despite plumbing failures. And it was kind of fake it till you make it was the kind of ethos that was there.
它某种程度上发布了。所以那就在那里有一种管道式的张力。但另一件事是，这个愿景在某种意义上导致创始人创造了一种文化，几乎没有员工可以对管道提出担忧。我的意思是，如果你这样做了，你就会面临诉讼，例如。而且，你知道，他们有一个由外交官和像乔治·舒尔茨等人这样的高级人士组成的董事会，他们离医学诊断的世界很远。你可以想象发生了什么。尽管管道失败，员工却无法吹哨。而且那是一种“假装直到你成功”的理念。
And then the wheels came off. And that was when everything kind of got exposed. And of course, it wasn't just the people within the organization who got taken in by the poetry. The company raised hundreds of millions of dollars. It was valued at one point in the billions. And eventually, the leaders were found guilty of fraud and sentenced to prison. Absolutely. And that was the sad unraveling of all of this.
然后轮子脱落了。那就是一切都被曝光的时候。当然，不仅仅是组织内部的人被诗歌所吸引。该公司筹集了数亿美元。它一度被估值为数十亿美元。最终，领导者被判欺诈罪并被判入狱。绝对是这样。而这就是这一切悲惨的解体。
Absolutely. So, Hucky, I think many people have the experience of coming up with a great concept for a business or an organization, but then struggle to make that idea a reality. We heard from a listener named Sarah who wants to create a non-profit, home where people grappling with loneliness or grief can stay a week or two for free. But she can't seem to get it going. Here she is. I have a lot of ideas around how to fund it, how to sustain it, but my biggest hurdle is the actual house. I would use my own home if I could, but that's not realistic. I would love to be
绝对是这样。所以，哈吉，我认为许多人都有想出一个伟大的商业或组织概念的经历，但随后却努力使那个想法成为现实。我们收到了一位名叫莎拉的听众的来信，她想创建一个非营利组织，一个让那些与孤独或悲伤作斗争的人可以免费住上一两周的家。但她似乎无法让它运转起来。她在这里。关于如何资助它，如何维持它，我有很多想法，但我最大的障碍是实际的房子。如果可以的话，我会用我自己的房子，但这不现实。我很乐意……
able to do this in a couple of years when I retire. And so, yeah, that's basically my big question is how do I how do I go about getting this big idea off the ground? So I think many people struggle with questions like this, Hagi, going from a dream to a blueprint, what would you say to Sarah and to people in similar situations?
能够在几年后我退休时做到这一点。所以，是的，这基本上是我最大的问题，就是我该如何让这个宏大的想法落地？所以我认为许多人都在为这样的问题而挣扎，哈吉，从梦想走向蓝图，你会对莎拉和处于类似情况的人说什么？
So Sarah, thank you for your question. Your idea is a wonderful idea. It brims with generosity. But after having listened to you, here are my quick reaction, Sarah. It seems to me that part of what you're doing is you're in the deliberation phase and you've got to get to the implementation phase. And psychologists refer to this as crossing the Rubicon, as Caesar crossed the Rubicon in ancient Rome and did all the things that he did subsequently. So what would help you to cross the Rubicon is the key question.
所以莎拉，谢谢你的提问。你的想法是一个美妙的想法。它充满了慷慨。但在听了你的话之后，这是我快速的反应，莎拉。在我看来，你正在做的一部分是你处于审议阶段，你必须进入实施阶段。心理学家称之为“跨越卢比孔河”，正如凯撒在古罗马跨越卢比孔河并随后做了所有他做的事情一样。所以什么能帮助你跨越卢比孔河是关键问题。
And listening to you, it seems to me, you're focusing on the house as a constraint. What I'm kind of wondering is, might you actually have a prototype of your idea? Because at the moment, it's in your head. Can you develop like a little model or a prototype? And use that prototype to talk to people who can help you, not just the people who can stay there, but the others who can potentially help you execute this vision. And the point of the prototype is it's getting you to cross the Rubicon.
听着你的话，在我看来，你把房子当作一种约束。我有点好奇的是，你是否真的可以有一个你想法的原型？因为目前，它在你的脑海里。你能开发一个小模型或原型吗？并使用那个原型与可以帮助你的人交谈，不仅是那些可以住在那里的人，还有其他可能帮助你执行这个愿景的人。而原型的意义在于它让你跨越卢比孔河。
It's actually creating conversations. about with people, and it'll help you refine things. You might realize when you do that, maybe you don't need a house. Maybe you might need something intermediate. So there are all these possibilities. So that's what I'd recommend, Sarah. So many listeners wrote in to say that they struggle to identify the problems that might be in their way. Here's a question from a listener named Kendra.
这实际上是在与人进行对话，它会帮助你完善事物。当你这样做时，你可能会意识到，也许你并不需要一栋房子。也许你需要的是某种过渡性的东西。所以，所有这些可能性都是存在的。这就是我的建议，莎拉。许多听众写信来说，他们很难找出阻碍他们前进的问题。这是一位名叫肯德拉的听众提出的问题。
How can one expedite that process of identifying what is getting in the way? the way of making a vision a reality. So in some ways, Hagi, this might be an extension of the previous question. As you're launching a new endeavor, you might be aware that there are plumbing problems that you are not aware of, that there are challenges that you need to surmount. How do you figure out what those challenges are when you're starting out for the first time? That's a great question. What I would do is I would actually be.
一个人如何才能加快识别阻碍因素的过程？阻碍将愿景变为现实的因素。所以从某种程度上说，哈吉，这可能是上一个问题的延伸。当你开启一项新事业时，你可能意识到存在一些你尚未察觉的“管道”问题，存在一些你需要克服的挑战。当你第一次开始时，你如何找出这些挑战是什么？这是一个很好的问题。我会做的是，我实际上会……
begin by observing users of the potential product or service that you have in mind. Because once you start observing people using your product, you know what the need is, and then you can actually figure out what to do. Let me give you a quick example, Kendra, in the hope it might help you. At Stanford, one of the things we teach executives is, you know, how do you develop a new product? And one of the things we tell them is the answer isn't sitting on a chair in a classroom. You got to go out and observe users. So what did we do?
从观察你心目中潜在产品或服务的用户开始。因为一旦你开始观察人们使用你的产品，你就知道需求是什么，然后你就能真正找出该做什么。肯德拉，让我给你举个简单的例子，希望对你有帮助。在斯坦福大学，我们教给高管的事情之一是，你知道，你如何开发一个新产品？我们告诉他们的一件事是，答案不是坐在教室的椅子上想出来的。你必须走出去，观察用户。那么我们做了什么？
Took them to San Francisco Airport. We were working with JetBlue. They were, if you will, quote, the client. And we asked people to observe interactions at San Francisco Airport. One team quickly observed a distraught young child, copiously crying because the airline had misplaced the pet. This was some other airline, not JetBlue. And they came back with this and they said, how do we help this person? And very quickly it became apparent to them, hey, this is an extreme case.
我们带他们去了旧金山机场。我们当时正在与捷蓝航空合作。他们是，如果你愿意的话，所谓的“客户”。我们请人们观察旧金山机场的互动。一个团队很快观察到一个心烦意乱的小孩，因为航空公司弄丢了宠物而哭个不停。这是另一家航空公司，不是捷蓝航空。他们带着这个发现回来，说，我们如何帮助这个人？很快他们就意识到，嘿，这是一个极端案例。
We could design a system to reduce the probability of a pet being misplaced to zero, but it would be very, very expensive. Instead, what they did was, how can we serve customers with pets? And what did they do? They actually pitched the idea to the chairman of JetBlue. and said JetBlue ought to have a pet class for customers. And, you know, the chairman of JetBlue said, I understand first in the economy, you know,
我们可以设计一个系统，将宠物丢失的概率降为零，但这会非常、非常昂贵。相反，他们做的是，我们如何服务携带宠物的客户？他们做了什么？他们实际上向捷蓝航空的董事长提出了这个想法，说捷蓝航空应该为客户设立一个“宠物舱”。而且，你知道，捷蓝航空的董事长说，我理解头等舱和经济舱，你知道，
what are the markers of this pet class? And people said, well, all that you need is a channel on the TV screen in front of you. It's a channel called the Pet Channel. You pay 30 bucks. You can see spark in the hold. And you can see temperature and you can see whether there's enough water there. Those are the two things people worry about when they think about pets. And I still recall the JetBlue chairman patting his head and saying,
这个宠物舱的标志是什么？人们说，嗯，你所需要的只是你面前电视屏幕上的一个频道。它叫“宠物频道”。你付30美元。你可以看到货舱里的宠物。你可以看到温度，你可以看到是否有足够的水。当人们想到宠物时，这是他们担心的两件事。我至今仍记得捷蓝航空的董事长拍着头说，
why didn't we think of this? So observing users, I think, is the key because what that will give you are hypotheses, ideas, and so forth. Sometimes when we're trying to launch a new project, Huggie, we don't actually have the skills needed to attend to the plumbing. Listener Stanislav called in with a question about the transition from being an employee to an entrepreneur. There's a lot of skills that need to be learned that really are prerequisites to having an idea get off the ground. And some of the ones that are really undervalued or maybe under discussed is just how long it takes to build your network.
我们怎么没想到这一点呢？所以我认为观察用户是关键，因为这会给你提供假设、想法等等。有时当我们试图启动一个新项目时，哈吉，我们实际上并不具备处理“管道”所需的技能。听众斯坦尼斯拉夫打来电话，询问关于从员工转变为创业者的问题。有很多技能需要学习，这些确实是让一个想法落地的前提条件。其中一些被严重低估或讨论不足的技能，仅仅是建立你的人脉网络需要多长时间。
You need to have people who have experience in this, people who can help you. And then the other major skill would be to learn marketing. And that's a whole industry and a whole skill set that needs to be learned before any new business, any new venture, any new idea has a chance to really flourish. And these things take an extremely long amount of time and effort to accomplish. And a lot of times I feel like it's these exact issues that kill early entrepreneurs in the beginning simply because they don't plan for them. They're focused on the product,
你需要有经验的人，能帮助你的人。另一个主要的技能是学习市场营销。这是一个完整的行业，也是一套完整的技能，在任何新业务、任何新创业项目、任何新想法有机会真正蓬勃发展之前，都需要学习这些。这些事情需要极长的时间和精力才能完成。很多时候我觉得，正是这些问题在初期扼杀了早期的创业者，仅仅因为他们没有为这些问题做计划。他们专注于产品，
and they're still believing this outdated axiom of if you build it, they will come, which is simply insufficient. So Stanislav's comment makes me think of the idea that we often don't know what we don't know, Huggie. How does one address this sort of problem in the context of launching a new company or getting an idea off the ground?
他们仍然相信“如果你建造它，他们就会来”这种过时的公理，这显然是不够的。所以斯坦尼斯拉夫的评论让我想到了一个观点，即我们往往不知道自己不知道什么，哈吉。在创办新公司或让一个想法落地的背景下，一个人该如何解决这类问题？
I think in many ways, part of what Stanislav is talking about is going from a job to become an entrepreneur requires momentum and requires expertise, requires networks and requires knowledge. And all of those things, of course, make a lot of sense. Having said that, my own experience of people making this journey is most entrepreneurial ventures, they begin as side projects by people doing a real job. You know, either the real job is uninteresting or alternatively the real job that they're currently doing has surfaced the problem that the company they're working with is uninteresting.
我认为在很多方面，斯坦尼斯拉夫所谈论的部分内容是，从一份工作转变为创业者需要动力，需要专业知识，需要人脉，也需要知识。所有这些事情当然都很有道理。话虽如此，我个人观察人们走上这条道路的经验是，大多数创业项目都是从人们做一份正式工作时的副业开始的。你知道，要么是正式工作没意思，要么是他们目前所做的工作揭示了他们所在公司存在的问题，而这本身就很有趣。
And then, you know, part of what you do is take it forward. So being in a company already gives you access to some people, if not all of the people you require in a network. Let me give you an example of a student of ours who actually went through that experience. It was a very smart student with a biotechnology background. And, you know, we encourage students at Stanford, not just to take courses in the business school, but to hang out in other parts of the university. Well, this guy went and hung out in the medical school.
然后，你知道，你所做的一部分就是把它推进下去。所以，已经在一家公司工作让你有机会接触到一些人，如果不是你人脉中所需的所有人的话。让我给你举一个我们学生的例子，他确实经历了那种体验。那是一个非常有才华的学生，有生物技术背景。而且，你知道，我们在斯坦福鼓励学生，不仅要修商学院的课程，还要去大学的其他地方转转。嗯，这家伙去了医学院。
And soon after, he actually persuaded a medical school student to actually drop out a medical school and join him in a venture. And what's the venture they came up with? Super simple idea. Ogmedics. You go to a doctor. and what does the doctor do if you have a half an hour meeting? They're spending 15 minutes updating data. They have their back turned towards the patient, in other words. What does Ogmedics do?
不久之后，他实际上说服了一名医学院的学生退学，加入他的创业项目。他们想出的创业项目是什么？超级简单的想法。Augmedics。你去看医生，如果你有半小时的会诊时间，医生会花15分钟更新数据。换句话说，他们背对着病人。Augmedics做了什么？
Augmedics freeze the doctor from this tyranny of record updating. You instead can have a conversation with the patient and provided the patient gives consent. There's actually a scribe in Bangalore who's actually paying attention to the notes that are being developed and often prompts the physician. Oh, the patient said this, but the patient's grandfather had a similar malady. It's very hard for a doctor to summon all of this knowledge in the course of a conversation with the patient. And very quickly, they were able to show hospitals and health care organizations that they could actually improve the productivity of doctors by 25%. And what happens now. Ogmedics is there virtually in most hospitals, most things. But how did the guy develop
Augmedics将医生从这种记录更新的暴政中解放出来。你反而可以与病人进行对话，只要病人同意。实际上在班加罗尔有一名速记员在关注正在生成的笔记，并经常提示医生。哦，病人说了这个，但病人的祖父有类似的疾病。医生很难在与病人交谈的过程中调动所有这些知识。很快，他们就能向医院和医疗机构证明，他们实际上可以将医生的生产力提高25%。现在发生了什么？Augmedics几乎在大多数医院、大多数地方都存在。但那个人是如何开发
it? He found an opportunity, observed something that in retrospect is obvious, but nobody paid attention to it. What he did was he solved an orphan problem. Doctors complained, hey, we're wasting our time updating. Patients said, what is happening? Why isn't the doctor spending more time me. Even though people complained nobody did anything until this guy went and did it, of course, with his co-founder who was a medical school student. Hopefully this gives you an idea. The key is not all the resources you need, but the key is observing the orphan problem that you need to address. When we come back, how the metaphor of poetry and plumbing applies to context outside of work. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
它的呢？他发现了一个机会，观察到了一些事后看来显而易见，但没人注意到的事情。他所做的是解决了一个“孤儿问题”。医生抱怨说，嘿，我们浪费时间在更新记录上。病人说，发生了什么事？为什么医生不花更多时间陪我？尽管人们抱怨，但没人采取行动，直到这家伙去做了，当然，还有他那名医学院学生的联合创始人。希望这能给你一些启发。关键不在于你所需的所有资源，而在于观察你需要解决的“孤儿问题”。回来后，我们将探讨诗歌与管道的隐喻如何应用于工作之外的环境。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When you're starting a project, it's easy to get lost in the romance of it. You have a brilliant idea. You cannot wait to make it happen. But soon, you have to do the hard work of transforming that idea into reality. At Stanford University, Hagi Rao says many would-be entrepreneurs and leaders often focus on the poetry of their ideas. They neglect the plumbing, the messy and sometimes dirty mechanics, of putting those ideas into practice.
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当你开始一个项目时，很容易沉迷于它的浪漫色彩。你有一个绝妙的主意。你迫不及待地想实现它。但很快，你就必须做将那个想法转化为现实的艰苦工作。在斯坦福大学，哈吉·拉奥说，许多准创业者和领导者往往专注于他们想法的“诗意”。他们忽视了“管道”，即把这些想法付诸实践时那些混乱、有时甚至肮脏的机制。
Huggie, I'd like to start by acknowledging that one reason many organizations ignore the plumbing is because it can sometimes be boring. Someone needs to fill out the spreadsheets. Someone has to do the bookkeeping. Someone has to make sure the money owed to a company actually gets paid. Lots of these are not glamorous jobs. They involve repetition and attention to detail. But if the jobs are not done, everything goes kaput.
哈吉，我想先承认，许多组织忽视管道的一个原因是它有时很无聊。有人需要填写电子表格。有人必须做记账工作。有人必须确保欠公司的钱确实能收回来。这些工作很多都不光鲜。它们涉及重复和对细节的关注。但如果这些工作没做好，一切都会完蛋。
Can you talk a moment about the role of boredom, Huggy, in pushing us towards poetry over plumbing? That's a truly beautiful question. The first thing is, as you very rightly point out, plumbing is devalued in organizations. Good plumbers are actually people who help the organization to avoid problems, to prevent them in the first place.
你能谈谈无聊在推动我们走向诗意而非管道方面的作用吗，哈吉？这是一个非常美妙的问题。首先，正如你非常正确地指出的那样，管道在组织中是被贬值的。好的管道工实际上是那些帮助组织避免问题，从一开始就预防问题的人。
So the problem is their contribution is not visible in contrast to somebody who's dealing with a crisis and rallying people and doing all of these kinds of things. Now, plumbing doesn't just mean the attention to detail. Plumbers also are the best coordinators. And interestingly enough, people who are plumbers, when they do this kind of integrative work, particularly when the coordination is done by women,
所以问题在于，与那些处理危机、召集人员并做所有这些事情的人相比，他们的贡献是不可见的。现在，管道不仅仅意味着对细节的关注。管道工也是最好的协调者。有趣的是，那些做这种整合工作的管道工，特别是当这种协调工作是由女性完成时，
it's actually derisively characterized as sort of, if you will, office house. And, you know, the important thing to keep about plumbing is, while plumbing may be boring to others, it's not necessarily boring to the plumber. So that's the challenge for plumbers. We heard from one plumber at an organization who feels like her contributions are not valued, exactly as you were describing. Listener Amanda says she's been with the same company for 12 years and worked her way up to the position of vice president, but recently her boss reassigned her. He limited most of what mattered to me about the job.
它实际上被嘲讽地描述为，如果你愿意的话，某种“办公室杂务”。而且，你知道，关于管道要记住的重要一点是，虽然管道对其他人来说可能很无聊，但对管道工来说并不一定无聊。这就是管道工面临的挑战。我们从组织中的一位管道工那里听说，她觉得自己的贡献没有得到重视，正如你所描述的那样。听众阿曼达说，她在同一家公司工作了12年，一路晋升到副总裁职位，但最近她的老板重新分配了她的工作。他限制了大部分对我来说重要的工作内容。
To him, he just changed my job description, and to me he fired me. You know, I'm not as motivated by the idea of doing something great, but I am incredibly motivated by, making someone's life easier. And it's difficult for me to focus on greatness and not focus on things like scaling it or ease of use or whatever,
对他来说，他只是改变了我的职位描述，而对我来说，他解雇了我。你知道，我并不是因为做伟大的事情的想法而受到激励，但我确实因为让某人的生活变得更轻松而受到极大的激励。对我来说，专注于伟大而不专注于诸如扩展它或易用性之类的事情是很困难的，
like who's having a hard time because of this. And I do wonder if organizations don't value plumbing, if they just have to fail, I guess that's what I wonder. So Hucky, there's a lot here. You can hear the pain in Amanda's voice. Of course, we don't know all the details of what's happening. We don't know the interpersonal dynamics involved.
比如谁因为这个而过得很艰难。我确实想知道，如果组织不重视管道，如果他们注定要失败，我想这就是我想知道的。所以哈吉，这里有很多内容。你可以听到阿曼达声音里的痛苦。当然，我们不知道正在发生的事情的所有细节。我们不知道涉及的人际动态。
But it seems like in this case, it's Amanda who cares about the plumbing. How would you advise both leaders and followers to negotiate what needs to get done? I was actually very touched by Amanda's question and the sense of loss that suffuses the question. having said that here were some thoughts that crossed my mind and my hope is they might actually help you and others who are in a similar situation such as yours. The way I heard you were, Amanda, was, hey, you had a footprint and you had a job, if you will, that was kind of associated with the footprint and what your boss did was he reassigned you and listening to you clearly and very understandably experienced this as loss and something that diminishes you,
但看起来在这个案例中，是阿曼达关心管道。你会建议领导者和追随者如何协商需要完成的事情？我实际上被阿曼达的问题以及问题中弥漫的失落感深深打动了。话虽如此，这里有一些掠过我脑海的想法，我希望它们能真正帮助你和其他处于类似情况的人。阿曼达，我听到的你是这样的：嘿，你有一个立足点，你有一份工作，如果你愿意的话，它与那个立足点相关，而你的老板所做的是他重新分配了你的工作，听着你，显然且非常可以理解地将此视为一种损失，一种削弱你的东西，
so to speak. In any organization, when a job change comes across as a surprise, to my mind, it is a failure of leadership. You ought not to have been surprised at all, but if it came to you as a surprise, I think clearly there could have been lots of things that could have been done better. and we can of course spend time on it. But what I would suggest that you think about Amanda is how this might potentially be freeing for you. Because one of the challenges all of us have to do with jobs is we love to add things to our remit.
可以说。在任何组织中，当工作变动让人感到意外时，在我看来，这是领导力的失败。你本不应该感到惊讶，但如果它让你感到意外，我认为显然有很多事情本可以做得更好。我们当然可以花时间讨论它。但我建议你考虑的是，阿曼达，这可能如何潜在地让你获得自由。因为我们所有人处理工作时面临的挑战之一是，我们喜欢在职责范围内增加东西。
In fact, we think the bigger a job, the better it is. But the corresponding consequences when we add, we add. overwhelm ourselves. And not only that, we become thinly spread like peanut butter on a slice of toast. Now, it seems to me you already have a wonderful mission. You know, and the mission is to make life easier for people. You are a friction fixer, Amanda. And that's incredible.
事实上，我们认为工作越大越好。但当我们增加时，相应的后果就是我们让自己不堪重负。不仅如此，我们变得像涂在吐司片上的花生酱一样薄。现在，在我看来，你已经有了一个美妙的使命。你知道，这个使命就是让人们的生活变得更轻松。你是一个“摩擦力修复者”，阿曼达。这太不可思议了。
And so what you may want to think of doing is this job change doesn't require new skills, you need to activate as it were a new version of yourself. So the question you ought to ask yourself is, how do I multiply my curiosity with generosity in the job? Because you want to actually make life easier for people, as you said. And I think the more you summon curiosity and generosity and think of multiplying that, Amanda, you'd be in a better position, as will the people who obviously kind of depend on you for your expertise and your contribution. The other option, of course, for you always is to move to another company, but as you know, the grass sometimes appears greener on the other side, and that's a temptation, an issue that you need to be cognizant about. But thank
所以你可能想考虑的是，这次工作变动不需要新技能，你需要激活一个新版本的自己。所以你应该问自己的问题是，我如何在工作中将我的好奇心与慷慨相乘？因为你确实想让人们的生活变得更轻松，正如你所说。我认为你越是召唤好奇心和慷慨，并考虑将其相乘，阿曼达，你就会处于更好的位置，那些显然依赖你的专业知识和贡献的人也会如此。当然，对你来说另一个选择总是换到另一家公司，但正如你所知，草有时看起来在另一边更绿，这是一个你需要意识到的诱惑和问题。但非常
you so much for your candor and your honesty. So, Huggie, plumbing and poetry, of course, are metaphors, and I can well imagine both, you know, bosses and employees listening to the segment, and each believing that they care about the plumbing, even though they care about very different things. How do organizations, how do leaders and followers resolve this tension, Hagi? If we really look at leaders, what the evidence shows is people who are very powerful in organizations, they actually search very little because they have no need to. And so one consequence of that is you can actually have tunnel vision. You may also lack the ability to understand jobs three to four levels underneath you.
感谢你的坦诚和诚实。所以，哈吉，管道和诗意当然是隐喻，我可以想象老板和员工都在听这个片段，每个人都认为他们关心管道，尽管他们关心的是非常不同的事情。组织、领导者和追随者如何解决这种紧张关系，哈吉？如果我们真正审视领导者，证据显示，在组织中非常有权力的人，他们实际上搜索得很少，因为他们没有必要。因此，一个后果是，你实际上可能会有“隧道视野”。你也可能缺乏理解你下方三到四级职位的能力。
And if you don't know what is happening in a job three to four levels underneath you, you don't understand the plumbing issues well. And so you're either likely to ignore them or be derogatory or, you know, what have you. If you want to understand plumbing, be vulnerable. It seems to me that part of what we need is we need to get. leaders to actually see the organization kind of bottom up. In another lovely example of the gap between leaders and followers being reduced is this lovely idea of reverse mentoring.
如果你不知道你下方三到四级职位发生了什么，你就不能很好地理解管道问题。所以你很可能会忽视它们，或者表现出轻蔑，或者，你知道，诸如此类。如果你想了解管道，就要保持脆弱。在我看来，我们需要的一部分是让领导者真正从下往上地看待组织。在另一个缩小领导者与追随者之间差距的美妙例子中，是“反向指导”这个可爱的想法。
You know, some leaders in the C-suite now have mentors who are young engineers, teaching them about AI. And I asked one of them, hey, how come you're doing this? He said, hey, you know, I'd go home, I'd ask my son or daughter about this AI thing. and they didn't have much time, and I realized there are a lot of people in the age of my son or daughter in my company, they can teach me, and there you go.
你知道，现在一些高管层中的领导者有年轻工程师作为导师，教他们关于人工智能的知识。我问其中一个人，嘿，你为什么这么做？他说，嘿，你知道，我回家后会问我的儿子或女儿关于人工智能的事情，他们没有太多时间，我意识到在我的公司里有很多像我儿子或女儿那个年纪的人，他们可以教我，就这样。
And the moment the CEO said, I have a reverse mentor who's a junior engineer, what did other people in the C-suite do? They also found it easier to say, you know, I really don't know a whole lot about AI, and maybe our younger people can actually help me educate me and get me a little bit up to speed on AI. So all of these ways are ways of like bridging,
当CEO说“我有一位是初级工程师的反向导师”的那一刻，高管层中的其他人做了什么？他们也发现更容易说，你知道，我确实对人工智能了解不多，也许我们的年轻人可以真正帮助我，教育我，让我对人工智能有所了解。所以所有这些方式都是弥合，
if you will, the seeming divide between poetry and plumbing. We heard from a listener named Debbie about the risks of burnout for the people who are known as their organization's plumbers. She writes, plumbers are turned to all the time, at work, at home, in the community, in non-profit organizations. The plumbers get burned out. They are effective, and so they are counted on to get done what's needed to get done. And plumbers are surrounded by all.
如果你愿意的话，诗意与管道之间看似鸿沟的方式。我们从一位名叫黛比的听众那里听说，那些被称为组织“管道工”的人面临职业倦怠的风险。她写道，管道工在工作、家里、社区、非营利组织中一直被求助。管道工会精疲力竭。他们很有效率，所以人们指望他们完成需要完成的事情。而管道工被各种各样的人包围着。
sorts of people who cannot or will not help with the necessary work. What does it take to develop more plumbers? So I guess there's a two-part question here, Hagi. What can we do to help plumbers avoid burnout? And second, how can we develop more of them? Great questions, Debbie. I think your first question is spot on, because what happens in organizations is when they find a person like yourself, Debbie, who is a good plumber, what do people do? They rely on you. And of course, the more they rely on you, the more they abdicate their own responsibility to also be plumbers in their roles and in their jobs.
那些不能或不愿帮助完成必要工作的人。培养更多的管道工需要什么？所以我猜这里有两个问题，哈吉。我们能做些什么来帮助管道工避免职业倦怠？其次，我们如何培养更多的人？很好的问题，黛比。我认为你的第一个问题切中要害，因为在组织中发生的事情是，当他们找到像你这样好的管道工时，黛比，人们会做什么？他们依赖你。当然，他们越依赖你，他们就越放弃自己作为管道工在各自角色和工作中应尽的责任。
And that's part of the reason why, because others abdicate and others expect you to do that, plumbers become overburdened. But there's also another dynamic. And the other dynamic is plumbers also may seek to expand their own remit in order to become more indispensable to the organization, to become more powerful and perhaps more valued in the organization. The challenge for a plumber who becomes actually kind of overburdened is to actually think of simple ways in which you put time boundaries around yourself. Two studies are relevant here.
这就是为什么，因为其他人放弃了，而其他人期望你去做，管道工变得负担过重。但还有另一种动态。另一种动态是，管道工也可能寻求扩大自己的职责范围，以便在组织中变得不可或缺，变得更有权力，也许在组织中更有价值。对于一个实际上变得负担过重的管道工来说，挑战在于真正思考一些简单的方法，为你自己设定时间界限。这里有两项研究是相关的。
One study shows that people who are plumbers, they get interrupted often. How come people come to them for help? So the more you get interrupted, the less work you're able to do and your own productivity diminishes. The other thing is there are studies that show when people become overburdened with requests for help. The specific number can vary anywhere between 10 to 12 per week to 20 plus per week or whatever. Under those circumstances, what happens is plumbers begin to click on passive job advocacy. advertisements that cross their way, if you will. So how can we help plumbers in this context? A simple way of time-bounding things is to tell people, don't interrupt a plumber all the time.
一项研究表明，作为管道工的人经常被打断。为什么人们来找他们寻求帮助？所以你被打断得越多，你能做的工作就越少，你自己的生产力就会下降。另一件事是，有研究表明，当人们被寻求帮助的请求压得喘不过气来时。具体数字可能在每周10到12次到每周20次以上不等。在这种情况下，管道工开始点击他们遇到的被动求职广告。那么在这种情况下我们如何帮助管道工呢？设定时间界限的一个简单方法是告诉人们，不要一直打断管道工。
They have office hours. They're available Wednesdays 1-2 or 12-to-1 or whatever it is. Go ask them your questions and localize their helping time. That's one simple thing you can do. But the other thing, and this is inherent and implicit in your second question is, plumbers have to be recruiters. If you're not a recruiter and if you're not getting other people to join in the adventure of plumbing, it's going to be very, very difficult. And so now to the second question, how do you develop plumbers? My view in organizations is you should start developing plumbers from the moment you
他们有办公时间。他们周三1点到2点或12点到1点有空，或者其他什么时间。去问他们你的问题，并集中他们的帮助时间。这是你可以做的简单的一件事。但另一件事，这在你的第二个问题中是内在且隐含的，管道工必须是招聘者。如果你不是招聘者，如果你不能让其他人加入到管道的冒险中来，那将是非常、非常困难的。所以现在回到第二个问题，你如何培养管道工？我在组织中的观点是，你应该从入职新员工的那一刻起就开始培养管道工。事实上，新员工是你找出管道哪里不工作最好的来源。前几天，我在一家芯片制造公司。而且，你知道，设计芯片的人需要的不止一个电脑屏幕，而是两个，因为他们必须看很多东西。我走进这个组织去见CEO，我只是看到了这个我以前没见过的年轻工程师。我注意到他有两个屏幕。我说，你花多长时间才拿到第二个屏幕？他看着我说，你在这里工作吗？我说，不，我是斯坦福的教授。我只是来参观的。我注意到了，这就是我问你的原因。他看着我说，教授，我花了两个星期才拿到第二个屏幕。这个地方就像伊斯坦布尔的集市。
onboard new employees. In fact, new employees are the best people for you to find out where the plumbing isn't working. The other day, I was at a chip making company. And, you know, people who design chips, they require not one computer screen, but two because they got to look at lots of things. And I was going into this organization to meet the CEO, and I just saw this young engineer whom I hadn't seen before. I noticed he had two screens. And I said, how long did it take you to get the second screen. He looked at me and he said, you work here. I said, no, I'm a professor at Stanford. I'm just visiting. I noticed it and that's the reason I'm asking you. And he looked at me and he says, Professor, it took me two weeks to get the second screen. This place is like a bazaar in Istanbul.
你不知道你得敲哪扇门才能拿到东西。你就在那里看到了管道问题。你就在那里看到了管道问题。所以我建议更早开始。另一件事在我看来是，我们需要将管道纳入绩效评估过程。这样公司就能监控它、考虑它，并可能奖励它。没错。在之前的谈话中，哈吉，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是诗意与管道的理念适用于商业世界之外的许多环境。我们收到了听众梅拉的语音留言。
You don't know which door you got to knock to get the thing. And you see the plumbing problem right there. You see the plumbing problem right there. So I'd start earlier. And the other thing it seems to me is we need to embed plumbing into the performance evaluation process. So that the company is monitoring it, taking account of it, and potentially rewarding it. Exactly. One thing that struck me in our earlier conversation, Hagi, is that the poetry versus plumbing idea applies to many contexts outside the world of business. We received a voicemail from a listener named Meira.
她是一位拉比，她将你的想法与犹太传统联系起来。她在这里。我想让你知道，上帝在这方面也有他的问题，这就是为什么当摩西在西奈山顶收到第一套石板时，他下到山脚发现人们在崇拜金牛犊，并打碎了上帝之指写下的第一套石板。因为显然在创造人类之前没有足够的规划。那实际上是一个令人愉快的序曲，梅拉，当然把我们带回了摩西和石板，它非常令人回味。
She's a rabbi and she connected your ideas to the Jewish tradition. Here she is. I want you to know that God also had his issues with this, which is why when Moses received the first set of tablets on top of Mount Sinai, he came down to the bottom of the mountain to find the people worshipping the golden calf and smashed the first set of tablets written by the finger of God. because there wasn't enough planning, apparently, before the creation of the human being. That was actually a delightful overture, Maira, taking us back, of course, to Moses and the tablets, and it was wonderfully evocative.
我立刻想起，你知道，已知最早的诗歌实际上是美索不达米亚的《吉尔伽美什史诗》。你知道，这是在苏美尔时期。具有讽刺意味的是，尽管有带有所有这些诗意的《吉尔伽美什史诗》，苏美尔人却以其城市精湛的管道系统而闻名。污水、水，一切都经过非常仔细的考虑。但当我们思考当时苏美尔发生了什么时，
I was immediately reminded that, you know, the earliest known poetry actually is the epic of Gilgamesh from Mesopotamian. You know, this was during Sumerian times. And ironically, even though there was the epic of Gilgamesh with all of this poetry, the Sumerians were known for superb plumbing of their cities. The sewage, the water, everything was very carefully thought through. But as we kind of think of what happened in Sumeria at that point in time,
脱颖而出的是诗意。我们忽视了管道。而正是管道帮助苏美尔文明生存了那么久。否则，你会有疾病和公共卫生大流行，那会造成毁灭性的后果。所以，确实，它追溯到很久以前。哈吉·拉奥在斯坦福大学商学院工作。他与鲍勃·萨顿合著了《摩擦力项目：聪明的领导者如何让正确的事情变得更容易，让错误的事情变得更难》。
it's the poetry that stands out. We lose sight of the plumbing. and it was the plumbing that actually helped the Sumedian civilization survive as long as it did. Otherwise, you would have diseases and public health pandemics that would have decimated. So, indeed, it goes back a very long time. Hagi Rao works at Stanford University's Graduate School of Business. With Bob Sutton, he's the author of The Friction Project, how smart leaders make the right things easier and the wrong things harder.
哈吉，非常感谢你今天再次加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常荣幸，香卡。非常、非常感谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的谈话，并觉得《隐藏的大脑》有用或发人深省，请考虑加入《隐藏的大脑》Plus。这是我们仅限订阅者的播客源，我们会在那里为你带来你在其他任何地方都听不到的想法和对话。你也将有助于为每一集节目的研究、写作、事实核查提供燃料，
Hagi, thank you so much for joining me again. today on Hidden Brain. A real pleasure, Shankar. Thank you so very, very much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy today's conversation and find Hidden Brain to be useful or thought-provoking, please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus. It's our subscriber-only podcast feed where we bring you ideas and conversations you will not hear anywhere else. You'll also be helping to provide the fuel for the research, writing, fact-checking,
以及声音设计。要订阅，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以在apple.com/hiddenbrain注册。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
and sound design that go into every episode of the show. To subscribe, go to support. dot hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can sign up at apple.com slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及每一集节目所投入的声音设计。如需订阅，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果您使用的是苹果设备，可以在 apple.com/hiddenbrain 注册。我是 Shankar Vedantam。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。